a lot of people were hoping that Glenn
Younkin was gonna fix Virginia but just
because the governor is a republican
doesn't mean that they can change the
legislature and as long as there are
Democrats in Virginia and a lot of
influence yeah you're not going to get
everything you want so now we have this
story the Virginia Senate has rejected
three bills that would ban sex changes
for minors and we're going to talk about
that plus a bunch of other stories
pertaining to what's happening with kids
in schools with critical race Theory
with gender theory gender ideology and
things like that because joining us
today is a man who has a personal stake
in this fight and personal experience we
are joined by Jeff younger hey everybody
do you want to introduce yourself yeah
my name is Jeff younger my son is James
and my ex-wife has been trying to
transition him to a girl since he was
two years old and recently the Texas
Supreme Court allowed my ex-wife to move
my son to California to transition him
and that's is California a sanctuary for
gender it's a sanctuary State it's uh
Senate bill 107. so we are going to talk
about that plus a bunch of similar
issues because uh actually the
post-millennial had a bunch and Libby's
hanging out with us today as well hey
what's going on everybody this is Libby
Emmons with the post-millennial glad to
be here so before we get into it head
over to timcast.com become a member to
support our work directly click that
join us button if you appreciate the
work we do not only will you get access
to exclusive uncensored segments from
this podcast but you will help us with
our cultural Endeavors freedom of Stan
is coming along I've got photos I should
post them I'll post them after the show
I'll try to remember but they're amazing
this is going to be super super
incredible the new space we have the new
shows we're doing a morning shows with
with women kind of like the view but
sane women no not not unhinged and uh
we're trying to create physical spaces
as well so we have a coffee shop in the
works a lot of design work is going is
happening and um we're delayed on the
coffee product unfortunately because
there's a bag delay or something but
it's happening and it's all thanks to
you we need to create physical spaces
where people can come together make
allies share ideas and that's what we're
doing thanks to you so don't forget to
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share this show with your
friends and we also got Ian Crossland
hanging out what's up everybody happy to
be here I uh maybe we'll play it later
on the show I I saw some deep fakes of
my voice going around so a friend of
mine sent me a a deep fake voice
generator
it is the creepiest and scariest thing
I've ever seen it took two seconds to
upload a clip of Ian's voice and we can
make Ian say anything and they will oh
they will now here's the best part when
I tried it on me it didn't work why not
right I have no idea but I'm glad it
didn't really yeah it didn't work it
just sounded bad it doesn't sound like
me at all wow it weirdly just doesn't
sound like me and I'm like okay that's a
good thing maybe I got a weird voice and
I talk like a weird person you're immune
to The Matrix well maybe there's
something like most people talk a
certain way so the AI takes a person's
voice and applies it to like a standard
set of an algorithm that applies to most
people and then generates it and for me
it just didn't really work cool maybe we
can listen to those later we will we
will definitely play those we also got
surge pressing the buttons yo what's up
everybody how you guys doing at
surge.com Let's uh let's get started
with your story actually Jeff for those
that don't know what's happening with
you and your son do you want to give us
the the 101 sure so um starting about
two years old my my ex-wife decided to
transition my son to a girl we were
still married at the time and I told her
she couldn't do that she's a
pediatrician and she forced me out of my
house filed for divorce and then began
to really in Earnest try to transition
my son she began to present him to the
world as a girl she changed his name
without my consent with no legal basis
to do that my son eventually at three
years old we're still heading towards
divorce tells me that mommy says I'm a
girl so I took the first iPhone video
I'd ever taken
and if you go on YouTube you can find it
just search for mommy says I'm a girl
that went everywhere I'm an Orthodox
Christian
so it also went all over Eastern Europe
and Russian television got a hold of it
they were all perplexed like they think
of the Texas as a Bible Belt how could
it be how can this be happening in this
religious part of the country so then we
get to trial
um the psychology Community turned
completely against me all of them lied
at trial so far I've been able to prove
all these psychologists have lied so all
their testimonies been thrown out what
were they lying about whether my son
wants to be a girl or a boy
um in in the initial uh psychological
investigation they tried to cover for my
wife by saying she wasn't trying to
transition my son
and on that basis that I had made a
false accusation that she was trying to
transition him gave me less than
Standard Possession time with my son
so then we go to another trial in 2019
after the school started transitioning
my son behind my back
so I take my son to school and in boys
clothes they'd give him a dress make him
use the the girls restroom and it turns
out there's a loophole in all the 50
states around psychology that allows
psychologists to not inform parents
parents actually don't have a legal
right to the medical and psychological
records of their children I can explain
that later
so they they use that law to transition
by some without my consent I found out
about it I filed grievances with the
school district they said they did not
violate my parental rights by
transitioning my son without my consent
so we wound up going to a 2019 trial
in this little courthouse in Dallas
Texas and the top experts in the world
on transgender science from both sides
showed up in this courtroom only my
experts testified because the
depositions that I gave the experts on
the other side was so devastating they
would never put them in front of a Texas
jury I'll give you an example Johanna
Olson Kennedy who runs the largest
gender clinic in the United States
I directly asked her how do you justify
cutting healthy body parts off of
children
and she said well it if they're if
they're causing psychological distress
they're not they're not healthy body
parts so we cut them off
I asked how many total mastectomies have
you referred out for pubescent girls and
she said over 250.
so they didn't want to put that in front
how many hens and feet did they chop off
of boxes body dysmorphic people yeah
exactly well Joanna Olsen Kennedy also
said that um if peop if if girls end up
wanting to have their breasts back they
can just get fake ones yeah she did so
so but let's let's go back to the
beginning I mean how does how does this
begin how did your wife
decide that your son in her mind why is
she saying that your son is actually
trans well I first noticed it when she
would put him into timeouts and she'd
say things like you know don't be a boy
the monsters only eat boys and weird
stuff like this oh yeah what yes oh yes
but why is she doing it but she
testified in court to this this is what
she's testified I don't believe this
answer but I'm going to tell you what
she swore to in front of the judge at
the 2019 trial
she said first James asked for a girl's
meal in a McDonald's Happy Meal the
girl's toy in a McDonald's Happy Meal
second a few days later he asked for a
silver purse at Target that had a
multi-colored unicorn on it and James is
a painter he's still a painter and so he
wanted this purse and at that point she
thought he might be a girl that's what
she testified to because he liked the
unicorns I don't believe it he's like
unicorns yeah I mean I used to pretend I
was Wonder Woman I would dance around in
my backyard Swinging The Invisible whip
because I wanted to be an actor because
I'm creative and my parents had freaked
out and been like maybe that means like
no you're a creative yes you can pretend
to be anybody anything yes you can yeah
and children will conform themselves to
their parents wishes and all sorts of
ways and my son has told court-appointed
psychologists four of them
that the reason that he here's the other
fact that's really important for you and
your audience to know my son only
presents as a girl with his mom he's
never presented as a girl with me or
anywhere else at church or anywhere it's
only when he's with his mom that he does
this
so he's just told them straight up mommy
doesn't love me if I'm not a girl he's
told him that over and over again told
the judge that told the court appointed
psychologist
um what happened they they all
recommended that he be transitioned to a
girl all of them
I mommy doesn't love me if I'm not a
girl this is what he said yes that's
that's like what has that implicates the
mother I know what precipitated me
losing my son's all contact with my sons
um last year in July
was my son just straight up told the the
his counselor that he doesn't want to be
a girl he's getting embarrassed wearing
dresses at school
she didn't
uh even acknowledge that he said it
so he had an Apple Watch and he recorded
himself he said I'm going to record
telling you this
and your son did yes and she totally
freaked out threw him out of the office
and initiated a CPS investigation
against me
and told the the court that I had forced
him to say that
how old is your son now 10. 10 he was
nine when he said that
yeah did you force him to do it no no he
did ask me if he could record and I said
Texas is a one-party recording state but
our family's not sneaky so if you're
going to record people you should tell
them that you're recording them so just
tell her that you're going to record her
so so where is it where where where's
the story currently at now he's uh your
wife ex-wife took him to California the
judge uh allowed her to move to
California uh she doesn't have to tell
me where my sons are
so all I know is that they're in LA
county the only way for me to see my
sons is to arrange for supervised visits
in LA County
okay
um and it has to be someone that's
acceptable to the court
so the judge will be able to pick who
that is no matter who I pick they won't
let me do it
um she doesn't have to tell me any
medical procedures that she's doing she
doesn't have to tell me where they go to
school I'm actually prohibited from even
knowing those things wow yeah
so I haven't seen him in about a year
and six months now why both like who are
so two kids you said one's ten and then
one they're both ten they're twins yep
and they're not identical and so she's
saying one is and one is not trans yeah
and this is something that she did with
her daughters
so so if you want to know like when I
when I realized I was in trouble
it was during her pregnancy
we made a decision to have children
we're about two and a half years into
the marriage and I discover everything
she told me about her daughters was a
lie
so uh she had told me that her daughters
were adopted
well
her younger daughter was adopted from
her brother who's a three-time convicted
felon in California had to flee the
state because he was convicted again
he'll get life
who exposed this child to
methamphetamine in the womb and and knew
when she was a newborn and had all these
developmental problems so I didn't know
that I probably would have still married
and
um knowing that right because it's good
to adopt orphans like that I'm all for
that but her other daughter was from a
sperm donor and I would not have married
or had I known that why not
well
it it was it would be like she wants to
have kids without that without a man
without a father interesting yeah and
both of the girls I didn't know this
either both uh Ann's sister is a lesbian
and both of these girls had been raised
only around women like I remember
going out and running you know foot
races with the girls
because she basically abandoned her
girls to me so like I am the one who had
to take him to school do all their
homework
you know uh everything all the chores in
the house she worked 80 hours a week at
her practice right and so I got got
these girls that I had to raise so we go
out and run foot races and stuff like
that and they just couldn't believe that
I was winning
like they they didn't know like boys can
run faster than girls wow they just had
not been around any men
and um and thought that was actually
very funny that they were learning that
and didn't know that but they were 10
years old and is just discovering that
for the first time sounds a lot like
that book that we bring up periodically
the one that's in front of you yeah
genderqueer yeah yeah have you uh have
you read that one I have not read it I
never heard about it I bought a copy of
that and read it myself yeah yeah it's a
story of how this uh this uh this woman
is not she said she's non-binary but
it's an abuse story yeah I couldn't read
till she was 12. yep she had to use old
crusted pads with blood flaking off and
she smelled so bad because of it the
counselor called her in and said you
have a hygiene problem so it's no wonder
she ends up of course you know
distressed well and the book ends like
the the most triumphant part of the book
is when she's deciding that she's going
to come out to her middle school class
yeah and like tell all of her students
that she's which is non-binary which is
like why do we need to why does anyone
need to do that why do these people want
to be about around children so so much
is odd it's odd and sort of distressing
yeah but so so so you're I I remember
when the the story first broke about the
court case and the videos with your son
and all that stuff but your son's 10 now
I mean 10 year olds have a decent amount
of of you know Lucidity so is is he
resisting is rejecting this is he
complaining about it well the remember
the last time I saw him was when he
resisted and they took him away from me
permanently and gave me supervised
visitation I get less visitation than
convicted pedophiles in Texas you know
what's crazy too though is early on in
the story I remember reading in the
Federalist there was
um a woman who was the mom of some
friends of your son who said that when
he was over at her house he wanted to
wear boy clothes and she like gave him
boy clothes yes and he just wanted to do
Rough and Tumble boy things that's his
normal State and her testimony she was
not allowed to testify to that no she
wasn't they they wouldn't let her why
would they pick her peace why
um I don't know why they wouldn't let
her do it but they wouldn't they
wouldn't accept her yeah yeah so a lot
of people don't understand how family
courts work and what the incentives are
in family courts people think of them as
you know an objective judge and this
sort of thing
but the way that family courts are
managed is they prevent you from
presenting contrary evidence that's why
I've never been allowed to select a
psychologist for my son
the course will never allow me to do
that the courts pick the psychologist
who will then present the evidence to
the court right now fortunately I've
been able to record them I've been able
to gather evidence and and actually
prove that they perjured themselves so
they've had to throw out all this
evidence but it's taken a lot of work
and it's cost me a lot of money to do
that right and most people can't do that
so family courts basically work off of
fabricated evidence that's number one
number two there's really no appeal from
family courts so family courts unlike
normal like civil courts or criminal
courts there's almost no appellate
options out of a family court so the
judges operate with no oversight and
just do whatever they want and third and
this is the big one
there are massive Federal programs that
were instituted in the late 1970s that
pay States trillions of dollars to tear
families apart
so it's so innocuous when I tell you be
like this is a great program but like in
Texas we get 66 cents on the dollar put
into the Texas treasury for every dollar
of child support that's paid
right so the state is now highly
incentivized to issue the maximum amount
of child support that's why they almost
all divorces got 50 50 prior to the
1980s and there was the skyrocketing of
divorces where one parent loses custody
and that was to maximize title IV
reimbursements to the states in Texas
it's half a billion dollars to the Texas
budget if if the the state is profiting
off of Child Support correct and in Most
states the judicial retirement fund is
funded from this money so the more child
support that's issued from the family
courts the larger the judicial
retirement
it's and it's a massive program it's the
size of the largest defense programs so
the incentives are absolutely huge to to
to get people to pay child support
correct and even married people to get
them to break up and then have to pay
each other child absolutely absolutely
yeah so because you would think the best
child support would just be 50 50
custody and let people raise their kids
the best child support is to raise your
own kid that's the best child support
but they don't do that most States
actually have laws prohibiting the
courts from doing that Texas has uh has
a family code in which it's assumed to
be in the child's best interest that one
parent get 24 of the time and the reason
24 was chosen precisely is it maximizes
title IV reimbursement to the state at
24 percent
so it has to do with how the state
calculates child support So Texas has
one of the worst child support systems
in the state it doesn't take into
account the income of both parents and
it doesn't take into account the amount
of time you spend with the child
so there there are fathers out there
with 49 of the time that are paying
maximal child support still wow but it
but again that maximizes the
reimbursement to the state I have a
friend of mine him and his wife came to
an agreement to do 50 50 parenting no
child support because he watches the
kids a lot while she travels for her
work and so it's all it all worked out
and they decided it's just better to do
it this way the state of Texas sent an
attorney
to argue in the case that they should
not be allowed to do 50 50 custody I
read a story about uh some celebrity guy
who had to pay massive child support and
then he and the wife both went to the
court together as friends and said hey
he's no longer working and doesn't have
this money anymore so we we both agree
it should be lower in the court said no
they won't do it because they get they
get a cut they get a huge Kickback yeah
wow now there's an even more evil
program that's related to this title for
e
title IV e pays the states to adopt out
orphans
what do you mean adopt out orphans so
whenever whenever CPS takes a child from
from someone and then adopts them into a
good family they get title IV
reimbursement funds and it's a lot of
money it's like 50k per child the state
gets that money yes it goes into the
state budget and where does it come from
federal government interesting yep so
what will happen in Texas is some
satellite office of CPS will get low on
budget and they'll go and find a white
baby under two years of old years old no
no medical problems from working class
parents who can't afford a lawyer and
then they take the child and adopt it
out and then they get fifty thousand
dollars for their budget that's how they
do it wow there's massive incentives uh
to split up families in this country and
that's why you've had the explosion of
divorce and Rancor so now you have the
majority of children in America are
being raised in fatherless homes did you
we passed 50 it's it's it look they're
uh it sure does seem like there is a
system in place whether intentional or
not to reduce the population
unquestionably that's this is the whole
you know you talk about this you call it
a conspiracy theorist right
um but they're blatant about it they're
absolutely blatant about it but I think
the agenda is not only population
reduction
but also to reduce the political power
of the middle class right if you've
you've been to Europe most of you have
been to Europe I've been to Asia a lot
as well nobody cares about Free Speech
there yeah nobody cares about gun rights
there there's one place in the world
where people care about free speech and
gun rights and that's the American
middle class yep they have to disempower
the American middle class to get rid of
these things and so the best way to do
that is to take fathers out of the homes
yeah well that's that's where you start
breaking Society down that's right
destroy the family unit 100 I mean
there's also definitely marriage
disincentives I blame Reagan
no fault divorce no fault divorce but
there's also all of these uh there's tax
breaks for you if you're a single parent
and then if you're married you don't get
those tax bills that's right wow and
it's a lot easier to get on to state
sponsored health insurance programs
unless there's two of you if there's if
if you're married it's harder to get on
them because you automatically make a
little bit more money yeah in Texas
yeah you can't get on the states the
state plan there was something about
this I I learned earlier uh that in
Texas I believe it was you need both
parents to consent to some sort of
transgender surgery for a child but then
your wife or your ex-wife took the kid
out of the state in order to bypass
Texas state law so at that point you
would think Texas would be like hey hell
no that we're going to the federal
government come on step in you can't you
can't just
leave our state and then break our law
against the will of one of our state
citizens I would think that that would
be the case yes
um so
um the my case has been carefully
reverse engineered by leftist lawyers
it's very clear
to Pro to prevent me from taking a
federal course of action
um what they did was my since my judge
issued an order allowing her to move to
California
it's very difficult for me to go into
federal court and challenge a local
judge's ruling
there's something called The Domestic
Relations exception in family court in
federal court a lot of people don't know
this but the federal court just has a
rule they don't take family court cases
they just don't take them
what like I told you there's no appeal
out of Family Court you're doomed
whatever the judge says goes and federal
courts won't take them there's a very
narrow exception to that on civil rights
grounds which I might be able to pull
off what would that be
so uh there's a there's a really good uh
U.S Supreme Court decision called Troxel
and Troxel establishes 14th Amendment
protections for parenting your children
and all of my judge's rulings violate
Troxel
so I'd have to get into a federal court
and the Big Challenge in federal court
is you it's very easy to dismiss Federal
cases
under rule 12 of federal as a civil
procedure so I'd have to really build an
airtight case that would survive a
dismissal challenge
I'm thinking about that right now a
violation of fourth and 14th Amendment
that's right yeah is uh and what's
interesting is in my 2019 trial that
that I won I got 50 50 custody no child
support and I got uh 50 50 on all the
conservative rights so she couldn't do
any medical procedures without my
permission I think I remember hearing
about that news but then how did she end
up getting to move to California here's
how it worked so she she retained the
most powerful law firm in the state of
Texas family law firm named Coons Fuller
they're also the largest donor to
political campaigns so Texas has a
loophole that you can buy judges
essentially if as long as you donate to
political campaigns political activity
is protected and law firms cannot be
recused from representing an accord even
if they gave them a lot of money so they
gave my current judge over thirty
thousand dollars
okay thirty thousand bucks so in a
transparently corrupt recusal proceeding
they bought a a judge Emeritus to hear a
recusal hearing and all the judge where
I won the trial her name her name is a
255th District Court
all she did she went on to Facebook on
the official page of the court and said
everyone in my court got a fair trial
which judges are allowed to say things
like that they're allowed to assure the
public that they are performing their
public duty that's not recusable but on
that basis they recused her and then I
wind up in this other court that this
Law Firm gave 30 30
000 to and this judge then
systematically stripped me of all my
parental rights using temporary orders
which is not legal in Texas but I have
no really course of appeal there's you
can't in Texas you actually cannot
appeal Family Court decisions you can
only mandamus them you can't actually
appeal them
so using these temporary rulings she's
systematically and what's interesting
that she moves to California so as a
temporary uh right under yeah and so
they want to push they want to go to
final trial now and establish that as a
permanent right that's the idea well the
thing with California too is California
has decided that they have no obligation
to follow the laws of any other state
that's correct so if if
by some miracle you ended up
um having a Texas Court say that your
sons should come back from California
California would refuse to their own law
they won't send them back
um the they they are obligated by law to
give my son gender affirming Health Care
they have to give it to them
and a judge can consent without either
parent consenting a judge can consent
that's a Scott weiner yep state senator
Scott weiner do you do you know if
they've begun any medical procedures
chemical or no because I don't get any
information so she's been there since
end of December and I have no
information on my son at this point it's
just this is a federal we need the
federal government to step in I I the
only issue with the federal government
stepping in is you have the president of
the United States who is in favor of
child sex changes
well yeah and the entire health and
human services department and the
Surgeon General but we still let me pull
up this uh article right here we have
this article from the post millennial
Biden's Surgeon General warns that 13
year olds shouldn't use social media
because they are still developing their
identity
Chris Elson wrote Vivek Murthy says he
believes 13 is too young for children to
be on social media platforms because
kids are still developing their identity
what about puberty blockers
so I think this shows the hypocrisy yes
it does yeah clearly really fully
just straight out hypocrisy yeah so you
have Vivek Murthy saying um the children
should not be on social media because
they're still developing their
identities but he would also tell you
that uh girls who are minors should be
able to get abortions without parental
consent and also that children should be
able to determine their own gender
identity so I'm sure Jeff you're
familiar with the story of John money
yeah oh yes absolutely uh do you have
concerns I mean obviously you have
concerns for your for your your children
over this
yeah I mean the way I put it to the jury
when I was put on the stand was very
simple I said you know if my sons go
with me
they have a chance at a normal life
if they go with her they have no chance
at a normal life and a good chance of
living a life of despair
and that's the choice that's the
Hobson's choice that we're giving all of
these children right and they're they're
so obsessed with puberty blockers
because the cure for gender dysphoria is
called puberty puberty is the cure for
gender dysphoria puberty is the process
by which you come to identify with the
social psychological and physical
aspects of your sex
that's what puberty actually is and so
they desperately have to block puberty
to maintain the gender dysphoria over 90
percent of these kids if you just don't
do anything just grow into normal adults
small proportion of them uh become gay
and in line with the normal population
and then a small percentage of them
continue to have problems this feels
like at least to a certain degree some
of this is experimentation like
definitely we we know from the story of
uh John money and what he did to uh was
it Brian and David whether Brian and
David that they both ended up killing
themselves in in different ways and it's
it's a it's a horror story now that
story is particularly horrifying because
uh John money was forcing them to
simulate adult activities on each other
when they were very young children yeah
so for those that aren't familiar with
the story I think most people are but if
you're not basically you had uh twins I
think they're identical twins they're
identical yeah uh and there was a
botched circumcision so John money
convinced the parents you know it will
raise one as a girl and one as a boy and
then I think almost immediately it was
uh was was Brian or was it it was David
David was the one who made to live as a
girl David knew that he was actually
male yes the whole time and it caused
Great distress so
that that's that's my fear in that
thinking though there is the argument
made by the left that that shows gender
identity is inherent in the individual
and that if a child is born male but has
a female Identity or wants to identify
socially as a female and you don't do it
you'll end up with a situation
well I I have a kind of an unusual take
for someone on the right I'm definitely
on the right
um and that I do think gender uh is in
in many ways socially constructed and
this always freaks people out right like
well how can you be a right well I
believe that but the social
characteristics that we have built up
around the biological sectors correct
yeah and in other words you you're born
male but you have to learn to be a man
your father teaches you how to be a man
you fall in the footsteps of your
forefathers and you learn how to be a
man to assume your duties and rights and
responsibilities as a man in your
society and that has to be taught to you
right that kind of thing has to be
taught to you but like everything else
the left wants to make it either or in
these very strange ways you know sure
there is a genetic component probably to
gender identity there's a gender there's
a genetic component to all human
behaviors right
um it comes up a lot in the context of
being gay people say well people are
born gay they're not born gay
um there is a genetic component to being
gay they know exactly what the genetic
contribution is because billions of
dollars have been spent on it it's
approximately equal to your to your food
preferences
and you're totally in control of what
you eat
so there's gen just because something
has a genetic component doesn't mean
it's outside of your volition yeah your
genetics can be altered by your
environment they can be turned on and
off I think this is phthalates and pcbs
there was a you know I've had the
conversation with a lot of uh
conservatives and you're bringing up
good stuff this is yeah exactly yeah
we've had people on I think even James
Lindsey and I've talked to a lot of
these people who say there's no such
thing as trans kids and I say I disagree
with that I think you we've we've
already seen the stories there was a
there was a birth control that women
were taking that resulted in their uh
female babies masculine masculinizing in
the womb and then invariably as they
tracked and they grew up to become
lesbians and they're like hey we just
realized that this birth control was
actually doing this to the babies in the
womb yes in the event the woman was got
pregnant despite being on birth control
they had masculinized female babies and
so you take a look at the Plastics this
is why we've been using glass bottles
for for our what do we do with plastic
bottles because some people just don't
care but I prefer to put everything in
glass because you have phthalates and
pcbs and that's just a couple of the
endocrine disruptors that we've we've
got research on so my my hypothesis on
this is you know you had Bill Maher who
said
why are we seeing so many trans kids
um you've got so many in California but
not in Ohio so either what did he say
either there's something wrong between
the states or we're creating them or
something that effect and I'm wondering
if the reason we're seeing a massive
spike in this is I do think this is a
social component because we've actually
seen that in research but I think
another component of this may be that
we've expanded the use of plastics
plastic is over everything phthalates
and pcbs in all of our food then you've
also had these stories about uh birth
control getting in the water supply
can't be filtered out and then people
are drinking it I think we are living in
piles of our own filth in cities which
is making Dirty Water full of endocrine
disruptors of any kind any kind and
you're going to end up with people with
people who are in the womb developing
and their brains are forming and either
through some kind of hormonal imbalance
some kind of chemical alteration through
phthalates a baby is born and they're
they they have it they have an inverted
gender identity it doesn't match their
body you also you can't discount the
social contagion though I mean we're
seeing like a 4 000 increase percent
increase in girls who are deciding that
they are actually boys we're seeing
clusters of girls all transitioning
together and and there are a lot of
stories about people who have taken
their children away from these School
environments and their kids immediately
transition correct and it's also very
trendy in some places where my son had
been going to school in New York City
Trans was very trendy and some of his
friends were coming in like one day they
were furries and the next day they were
lesbians and then they were actually
trans and then somebody else was trans
because his girlfriend was trans and she
was a lesbian now and like it would be a
whole it was a whole thing it was like a
constant every day there were like
different identities going around and it
was very trendy to be part of the whole
identity thing it's really empowering to
get people to believe you're someone
you're not that's part of why I became
an actor it's incredibly empowering they
love it I love it everyone and then you
get paid for it but then these kids I
think they just want that empowerment
part of it too though is we're talking
about puberty right so Jeff you brought
this up we were talking about puberty
what is puberty puberty is the process
by which it's you know development it's
the process by which a child becomes an
adult it's a coming-of-age process right
we've taken away so many of the
coming-of-age rituals we've killed our
Gods so you know we don't have coming of
age rituals in our religion anymore at
this point in the United States that's
not common we don't have a lot of
confirmations anymore about Mitzvahs or
anything like this so what we have for
our coming of our main Coming of Age
ritual in our country right right now is
coming out you can come out as something
that's like the only the only American
it's it's the American coming of age
right it's it's our rite of passage
right you come out as part of your right
of path always getting your driver's
license no it used to be getting your
driver's license but now that's 16 it's
18. is it like quinceanera thing yeah
quinceanera that's yeah that's like a in
Mexico right yeah in Mexico that kind of
thing I know that is there a male
version of that I don't know what they
do down there well you know you do like
a 16th birthday party but um it's not
the same kind of thing you know what I
mean like this is our main rite of
passage it used to be I remember when I
was a kid and the whole like everybody
wanted to lose their virginity as
quickly as possible this was like but
that's very different from what that's
different right yeah it's very different
but now you can you can go through a
rite of passage of coming out and what
are the things you get to do you get to
change your name you get to start
choosing your own clothes you get to
dictate how other people are going to
treat you you know you're going to treat
you're going to call me by this name
you're going to refer to me even when
I'm not there with these very specific
you know phrases it feels like uh a lot
of RPG video games your character will
start off as like training mode or
whatever so actually this reminds me of
MapleStory which I don't know if it
exists anymore but your character starts
in like levels one through ten you have
no specialty and then once you get to
level 10 you get to choose your class
like what are you what are you gonna be
and it feels very much like what they're
trying to do well there's one thing I
think video games do play into the
social contagion because a lot of boys
play girl characters in in fps Shooters
mainly because you just don't want to
look at a guy's ass
when you go to Thursday when you go to
third person you want to see a girl's
ass when you're flat right but third
person you but yeah if you play it in
third yeah I switch to third person you
can play it you know with a girl
character it's it's more pleasing to you
SEC the other thing though you mentioned
these pcbs we can we can actually
objectively quantify that so the United
States Marine Corps has grip strength
data going back to the Revolutionary War
they administered grip strength tests at
tons Tavern when they commissioned the
Marine Corps so it literally goes all
the way back to to the very beginning so
they have the ultimate longitudinal data
set grip strength among men today is 30
what it was 50 years ago
not me though I got good grip hell yeah
it turns out grip strength is one of the
best proxies physical proxies for
testosterone levels wow so the Marine
Corps won't even let you go to recruit
training anymore unless you show up for
a year of physical training to prevent
training deaths
that's how bad it is so the handshake
the handshake test that's real it's a
legit thing it's a legit thing it's
plastic I've heard that hanging is some
of the best things you can do for a
person like hang from a tree branch and
just well that's what the Marine Corps
has you do if you have weep grips just
hang really yeah hang for 20 minutes
before you get child you don't get to
eat until you hang wow that's what they
make you do yeah well sperm counts also
on the decline yeah which is another
great marker a completely objective
marker of testosterone levels this is
the crazy thing so if you look back at
like we used to drink Mercury to try and
cure syphilis these things didn't work
but the Hope was that you'd poison
yourself so much that I don't know what
they were thinking yeah I can't I can't
understand this like the people would
just die from drinking it what made them
think in any way would help them or like
oh well the simplest must have got them
but uh then we have asbestos yeah and
asbestos actually is fine until you
disturb it but then we started realizing
like hey if we're gonna start clearing
out these buildings and doing remodeling
all of a sudden people are getting
mesothelioma so we get rid of it now
here's the problem with pcbs they've
warped our mind
we are now in a as a society in a
delusional state
and when a person let's say a person
gets hypoxic you cannot save yourself
right that's why they say put on your
oxygen before putting the mask on
somebody else yeah if our society has
been plagued by pcbs and you wonder why
it is that you've got to divide between
urban and rural why the Democrats in the
cities believe this in people in the
country don't perhaps it's because the
people in the cities are gargling and
swimming in endocrine disruptors that
people who are on weld water are not and
I grew up on well water in a Farm and
Ranch in Texas so what happens then is
as a society that is assuming the
intercontractors are doing this yeah if
half of the mind of our society this
this body has been
it was altered in some way yes how will
you make a sound decision to correct the
behavior a person who is I actually
never thought of that that's a great
point right our our minds uh so it it's
it's not just this issue I mean it's
also drugs and everything else sure so
it's like if you can't think you can't
think your way out of it right if if you
were on a plane
the reason they say put on the your mask
before someone else's is because if
you're all hypoxic you die yes if one
person could get their mask on you can
take everything straight they can save
everybody but we're in a place now where
half the people aren't wearing their
mask and so when you're with your mask
on saying put the mask on they're
swinging at you and they're in in a rage
and then just collapsing you can't vote
your way out of it yeah you got to
appeal to the gut that's the only way if
the brain can't understand or is
incapable from desensitization you can
get their gut you know we we talked a
little bit earlier about the
depopulation agenda you know uh friends
in Europe and they always make fun of us
in America for the some of the crazy
stuff here the wokeness
the fact that we pay three percent on
our own money interest on our own money
and our own treasury is bizarre they
laugh about these things and I just tell
them I just tell them like maybe you
should have some mercy because it's
we're probably the most heavily
propagandized population in the history
of the world the most sophisticated
propaganda regime ever launched against
a people has been launched against
Americans and they can't actually see
reality right in front they'll deny the
evidence of their own senses it's it's a
bizarre experience
um and I I can tell you running for
office talking to Normie conservative
Republicans
many of them actually still believe the
Constitution constrains the government
and that we should make constitutional
arguments to restore the Republic and
you're like
Constitution has constrained the US
government in 100 years like it it's
it's a completely irrelevant document
like how can you still keep saying these
things it's because they're heavily
propagandized we should not
underestimate how effective the
propaganda has been to Warp
uh well those visions that the issue is
you've got
prominent
individuals who make a lot of money
just agreeing with whatever the machine
wanted them to agree with so to go back
to the you know oxygen mask analogy if
half the people in this country are
inundated with pcbs and other chemicals
that's damaging their brain or or
causing them to you know just have
alterations to their mindset
neurodivergence as it were yeah then
someone comes along and says I don't
know about that but if I agree with them
they'll give me money
that's what's happening you know the
famous observation that it's hard to get
a man to change his mind about something
who's being paid to believe it oh wow
yeah that's a good one it's a very
simple concept but you know the you know
the the basic operation of of prop
modern propaganda is to demoralize
people but I don't mean it in the sense
of making them feel bad I mean to
literally remove morals yes I was going
to ask because people often talk about
demoralization and have to half the
people think you're talking about low
morale exactly when you're talking about
the removal of removal of morals because
you can't understand reality without
moral reasoning this is also something
that Heidegger talks about this is why
artificial intelligence is impossible
because moral reasoning is required
right it's required to make judgments
about the world right but I wouldn't say
impossible I would just say it's not
going to turn out the way we want it to
a big part of what's been going on
though is that the uh no I'm sorry go
ahead no no it's okay I think that in a
lot of cases the goal of you know
whoever is doing this is to remove our
ability to make judgments that's right
you know they want us to not be able to
differentiate between right and wrong or
good and bad
simply because they want the order to
maintain well because they want to get
their thing across you know well it
turns out that discriminating between
right and wrong is the is is important
to discriminating between red white and
blue falling down going upstairs like
the apprehension of physical reality is
informed by your morality it turns out
there's a reflexive relationship between
the two and by removing this moral
judgment you can you can remove the
ability people to understand what's
happening to them and that's what's
going on too with the drag story hours
and everything is you have kids come in
they look around and they're like this
is super creepy and then the parents are
like no this is totally normal but
explain the the AI thing why do you
think it's not possible so
um what we're really doing with AI is
we're doing fancy curve fitting
so
um and we we put a nice name on it and
we do all stuff but what it is basically
doing is curve fitting to very
complicated functions and it can mimic a
lot of the decision-making abilities of
humans it can um it can be really
effective if it's layered so-called deep
learning
where it's layered so you're doing
essentially curve fitting on curve
fitting on curve fitting on curve
fitting but what it can't do
is things that that humans do it cannot
look at its environment and make
judgments independently about its
environment like one of the hardest
problems in AI
is to teach a system to just recognize a
kitten
it's an it's it's a notoriously
difficult problem to get it to just
optically recognize a kitten something
which which a two-week-old newborn can
do what do you mean it can't recognize a
kitten it can't it turns out that
kittens have a fuzzy enough look that's
very difficult for them to discriminate
it but yet a child with the kinesthetic
perception once it holds remember we're
talking about two week old infants yeah
that don't have object permanence
so when you remove it from their site
they think it doesn't exist anymore
that's why they get that's why you can
play peekaboo with kids because you
appear again out of nowhere right they
don't have object permanence so but they
you could teach a child that age to
discriminate a kitten but you can't
teach AI is very difficult to do we'll
get there I think though and one of the
also one of the hardest problems called
the the location problem what if you
just plop an AI down in a hallway and
get it to recognize where it is figure
out where it is this turns out to be
extremely hard without the contextual
information provided by innate human
knowledge about the world in some sense
what kind of what Kant was talking about
that there are categories of perception
by which we structure knowledge
that's not possible for AIS well I I
don't I think we just haven't developed
the technology to get there I think it's
possible that have you seen like the
Boston Dynamics robot yes I think you
can put uh some kind of algorithmic
learning uh system within it and let it
Mill about and eventually it'll start
discovering and mapping things and then
understanding and all that stuff no I
don't actually don't disagree that it
would do that but what I'm what I'm
disagreeing with is whether that's
intelligence
yeah let me give you an example I
suppose that goes to the question of the
Soul then ultimately sorta but actually
we can just restrict ourselves to just
mathematical logic you know in
mathematical logic there's two separate
categories of research one is called
Model Theory one is called proof Theory
when your computer is here do
mathematics or arithmetic they don't
understand what the numbers mean right
so it turns out that what mathematicians
are actually doing is they're creating
what are called formal languages
and these formal languages have three
particular elements that make them up
and they've been thoroughly studied
mathematical logic is like the
Linguistics of mathematics and studies
these languages they have one particular
property that natural languages don't
have
and that is that every grammatically
correct sentence is guaranteed to be
true
what do you mean by that elaborate so um
if you follow the rules of algebra
you don't need to know what the numbers
mean you'll get the right answer
as long as you followed all the rules
right you'll get the right answer you
could see symbols on a page and and know
that that was no that's called proof
theoretic reasoning so we're just using
grammar rule to simplify if I understand
that 3 as a symbol represents three
objects yeah you can represent that with
say sticks yes even if I did not know
what those represented if you knew the
rules of how the numbers I still get the
right answer yeah so that's how
computers do mathematics right the
computer doesn't know that two right
would be represented by two physical
right it doesn't know it two means it
doesn't know what it means but humans
usually do mathematics using model
Theory
where we the number means something in
mathematical logic a model is when you
actually assign meaning to the undefined
terms so if you're doing geometry you
have points and lines you give them some
meaning say a point is a DOT on a page
and a line is a straight A straight uh
you know ruler on a page you give it a
meaning well here's the amazing thing
about formal languages
um that any sentence that's
grammatically true just for proof Theory
without any meaning to the terms is
guaranteed to be true in all models
so it turns out no matter how you define
points and lines if the axioms are true
in that model all of the sentences will
be true too so all the theorems are true
that's not true in natural language
so what the AIS are really doing is a
kind of proof theoretic
way of trying to make their way in the
world it's not doesn't understand the
meaning of what it's doing this is uh
that's what you would find terrifying
about them I find the whole thing
terrifying because I think where we're
headed is I saw an ad for a program that
can
generate any video so everybody's been
playing with these various AI model
model uh art programs there was like
stable diffusion we did a bunch of bits
on the show where we like you know
Donald Trump hugging Joe Biden and the
photo's awful and doesn't really work
but now you've gotten what's that what's
that really popular one that everybody's
using that GPT no no no the picture
generator oh my gosh I use nightcaps
uh what was that you just bumped us off
it's because I took the mic off and I
just hit the wrong button oh okay so
sorry everybody's using mid Journey but
there's another app that can make videos
now obviously there's a big controversy
over deep porn where that streamer was
watching it and uh so I think where
we're going is
right now what we can see basically the
tools that exist it is entirely possible
to combine these things and say okay
give me the scene it's a it's a bar and
there's three guys and they're about to
have a fight yes you could create the AI
models then tell the machine to make
this scene with these models and it will
you will be able to write a movie and
then press go and it will apply the
script the character names the
description of everything I agree the
script can be put in and this is
possible literally right now all we have
to do is combine the components that
already exist and are purchasable you
can then take an existing script file
name description character sound of
their voice it's all in the script and
then the machine will render that for
you but here's the thing
that's technology today that we simply
need to connect it already exists yes
where we will actually go is you will be
sitting in your room and you'll be like
uh computer
make me a movie about Cowboys uh in 1870
and uh they awaken a dragon and he's got
to save his son and the Machine will
just generate everything instantly for
you right the scary thing to me that
about how nightmarish it is is we are
going to especially with Nora link and
VR we are going to tell the computer get
generate for me a world where I am the
king and everyone loves me and I have to
fight a dragon and then you put the
headset on and you go into this soulless
masturbatory fake reality yes that's
where we're headed yes that's where
we're headed yes directly I agree with
all that the question that becomes what
is humanity and what do we want Humanity
to be and what do we feel our value is
and do we have a value Beyond how we can
entertain ourselves I read a great quote
a long time ago and it said if humans
ever shake hands with aliens they will
be congratulating each other not over
over not because they've overcome
nuclear weapons but but because they've
overcome the Xbox that is everything
that we are doing as humans is to
trigger our dopamine yes you take a look
at how humans used to live and we talked
about with jackboxobic I think it used
to be the norm that you would be out in
the middle of nowhere struggling to find
food that you wouldn't always have
everything you needed then we figured
out how to basically isolate everything
so what do we do we take pure sugar
combine it with pure fat and then we
guzzle it down until our heart stops
working for yourself
doing that a while ago oh my God I mean
a dessert here and there is fine but
imagine this that we've taken beets and
we've extracted the sugar and Hyper
concentrated that we took an orange
which is delicious and healthy and we
smashed all that juice that one wasn't
even hard right that what we're doing is
whatever feels good but it's just a
light we're just basically electrocuting
ourselves over stimulating until we die
that makes me think we were talking
about earlier about morality because I
think some people conflate morality and
pain they think that if it's painful
that means that it's not moral but the
reality is a lot of painful things are
the moral thing to do you I wanna I
wanna bring something up in this vein
there uh so this is something my friend
sent to me earlier today and he I get
this text message with a very weird
audio clip of my friend telling me that
he's obsessed with Joe Biden
and now I'm just like what are you what
is this it's like not a very political
guy and then he sends me a link to
elevenlabs.io where you can add anyone's
voice I've I I put my voice in and I'll
just leave it at this I don't want to
name anybody because I don't want to I
don't this is a creepy thing but there
are a variety of different podcast hosts
I've uploaded I I took a sample of their
voice okay and I was able to deep fake
their voice in two seconds I'm not
exaggerating I clicked add voice drag
and drop MP3 thumb snap and it does it
so so first I'll show you this this is
speech synthesis from 11 labs this is
their generic atom it's what their their
default is I typed in this is not a real
person talking it's a deep fake let's
generate see what it sounds like
we need volume is do we have volume it's
generating that's what takes time cool
yeah got to give it a second this is so
freaky I heard my own voice earlier
today and we're gonna play your voice
this is not a real person talking it's a
deep fake let's try that again this is
not a real person talking it's a deep
fake there you go so you can type in
basically anything and um when I first
heard this I went well that's really
cool I've heard robot voices before I'm
not super concerned about it right but
then we decided to uh
oh which one should I play
here we go hi I'm Luke radowski and I
don't know how to pronounce my own last
name that's Seamus Coughlin by the way
well it's a deep fake of Sheamus
Coughlin of Sheamus that's Sheamus
that's Luke that sounded like Sheamus
that was Luke play that again
hi I'm Luke radowski and I don't know
how to pronounce my own last name I'm
gonna go with Sheamus I think that's
Luke hey what's up guys I'm Ian
Crossland and I'm not wearing any pants
today that sounds like Chris Poole no no
that sounded just like and I'm not
wearing any pants today ever ever I
really like that guy that does suck it's
really great just like bringing a piece
to the Middle East yup
um
you gotta let it play again Trump he's
the best president ever
I really like that guy he's like you
just gotta really great things like
bringing peace to the Middle East
um
so we have a whole bunch of different uh
uh should I play yeah it's so weird
because I guess I'm not responsible for
what comes out of that guy's mouth
dude don't tell Wesley I told you this
but we kissed last night I think we're
in love I do love Wesley by the way but
not like that so I don't want to play
other people's voices that aren't
affiliated with this company or the show
okay but um let me just tell you name
your favorite high-profile personality
it is freaky good you said some of them
you got that all those voice clips from
One MP3 that you that you sent the
machine
I took like five to ten seconds of
different people's voices
uploaded it there was no right five to
ten seconds there was no rendering time
it's amazing no rendering time you just
upload it and then I pressed the
rendering is when you type in the text
and we were able to make Ian say a whole
bunch of stuff and uh uh did you try
your voice my voice didn't work
do you have an example what no why would
that be because it wasn't I have no idea
it wasn't able to do it I I put in a a
not that large of a file because 10
megabytes is the maximum
and what came out sounded just kind of
like someone trying to impersonate Me by
talking quickly but it didn't sound like
me okay and my brother tried it didn't
work on him either so I'm good I'm glad
about that by the way but um this really
freaked me out because wow some of the
voices we were able to generate and
again the reason I'm not naming these
people because you have to imagine what
it would be like if someone were to play
your voice right it is freaky so what's
the upshot of all of this so we have
there's no upshot we have like someone
else I mean there's like so once we have
everybody's voice and deep porn and like
all of this stuff how are you ever going
to tell somebody who you are as opposed
to who the the fake you is people are
going to
take the voice of a famous actress and
they're going to put it in this and
they're gonna generate her saying things
like I love you sure I will marry you oh
you're a dream come true and then
they're gonna put their version sure yes
exactly that's the vanilla version then
they're gonna put their face on the body
of course and they're gonna put the VR
headset on and that's where we're headed
that's exactly so real life and now
imagine Nora link where you can actually
trigger sensory perception so now people
are just telling the machine create for
me celebrity X and run our honeymoon
wink wink you know where this is going
and then well you wouldn't even have to
say wink wink you would just do the
thing to the audience here I get it you
get it what concerns me I think what
you're mentioned earlier people do weird
stuff when they're by themselves like
yeah how the AI doesn't understand
context like humans do so if if the
creator of the program wants to alter
the definition of a word you're like I
want to go out for a horse ride with my
favorite and they're like okay change
what it means a horse means slightly and
like there's no no way to context could
the AI not like look at all horses
across all time and and decide what a
horse is yeah that that's what I mean by
curve fitting it can kind of generate
um a general image of a horse it can
even uh look at particular aspects of
horses and and do that it just doesn't
understand what it really is yeah and it
can't deliver that thing that is like
reality even with neurolink I think it
won't be able to quite do that well
that's what um I think Cipher said in
Matrix the reason everything tastes like
chicken Cipher said that right right
everything tastes like chicken because
the robots didn't know what they didn't
know what it tastes like yeah so the
thing then becomes too who's going to
maintain the machine
This was um I talked about this on the
show a bit my my Sci-Fi TV show idea
I'll give you the simple version did you
hear me talk about this before I have
yes go ahead so the general idea is it's
like the last city on earth and for some
reason the world is disrepair and
destroyed it's post-apocalyptic nobody
in the last City knows why there's like
maybe like 10 10 million people and so
they sent out scouting parties one day a
scouting party comes across strange
slender humanoid beings super thin and
tall in like Chrome suits that have
advanced technology that just wipe them
out and kill them and then the central
conflict is between these groups the
humans think these are aliens that came
and wiped out all of humanity the end of
the season is the Revelation and it's
like if this would ever to be made a
show totally be ruined by me telling you
this but the Revelation is that these
are actually humans and what happened is
around the end of the 20 the the 2000s
2099 or whatever humans began rapidly
migrating to pods with norlink just like
how cell phones were adopted in a matter
of a year or two right everybody had one
sure everybody eventually switches to
the digital economy and lives in pods
where all of their desires are
maintained so all the cities start
falling into disrepair because the only
thing you need to maintain chain is the
machines that have feeding tubes into
people's bellies like the Matrix to keep
them alive as they experience Paradise
however they want right but periodically
Scout groups have to go out to maintain
the machine refuel it
humans who did not go into these systems
don't know what happened because think
about it this way if you're trying to
understand the world right now but did
not have the internet would you know
what was going on no you'd have very
little idea exactly right so if all news
migrates to the metaverse right and the
people who outside of it don't have
access to it people who refuse to join
for religious reasons or because they
lived in the middle of nowhere and
didn't have strong internet just didn't
care so this is like so the city as it
exists in your scenario is like a few
Generations down the road a few
Generations after so like 21. yeah so
there's no records right they're they're
on they're going online and they're like
for some reason all internet records
just cease around this point and
newspapers stop getting printed
something wiped out Humanity we don't
know what but it's not that they got
wiped out it's that they're like they
migrated right they migrated to a place
where they were not they weren't
interacting anymore with right now
people in cities a lot of them have cell
phones you can you still know people
exist in cities you can still get a
newspaper you can still drive to the
city but if everybody left the city when
and underground into a pod to live
forever
you would never see them all you would
know is one day you walked into the City
and there were very few people this is
where the machine stops the EM Forester
Novella was written in what 1911. but
everybody goes underground yeah
everybody goes underground and they are
fed and cared for by the machine
um and they they basically like mating
happens by Machine hookups uh and all of
this stuff and then um the machine it
stops
stops 100 years later and then a whole
bunch of wacky stuff happens people are
being born in pods who've never
experienced the real world and will
never leave and there's only specially
designated humans who are reality Scouts
to make sure the machine is functioning
who go out periodically with advanced
technology because once everyone's in
the machine scientific simulation is
rapid and exponential with all the power
of the AI that they have so then they
have automation which can synthesize and
replicate and Advance Beyond people who
live outside the machine we're looking
at a situation where we're going to have
neural link we're going to have all
these deep fakes and whatnot so that you
can create your own reality inside your
own pod and we're going to have world
government that keeps us specifically
from moving around so that we don't mess
up the environment you'll own nothing
and be happy we'll own nothing will be
in our you could be in it right now
we'll have no freedom of movement you
could be in it right now for all you
know and then you're going to have like
one person who's you know yeah who's uh
who's Winston in 1984 or the
um the the Sun character in the machine
stops or K in the trial or the castle
you know you're gonna have this guy
who's just like looking around trying to
figure it out you're in it right now
well
I don't know right now you wouldn't know
have any of you seen like a classic
sci-fi film called Forbidden Planet from
the 1960s no it's about a civilization
that did this essentially they created
machines that could satisfy their every
desire merely with mental mental
stimulus
um and they developed a from that
machines that had out near infinite
power
um it just you know in the 1960s all
that all happened on Mars right and
um so you uh you find out that they
destroyed themselves towards the end of
this movie because what they didn't
count on was the ID
the monsters from the ID the
subconscious mind began to make another
reality a terrifying reality
that destroyed them
because one of the things that in such a
world where you're in a pod and you can
make any world your unconscious mind
could take control
and build things in the AI that you
don't necessarily want
and I always remembered that phrase from
that movie the monsters from the ID
Elon likes to talk about simulation
Theory yeah and the general idea is that
he thinks we're in one well the idea is
that within the next 10 years we will be
able to create virtual reality
indistinguishable from base reality
right and if that's the case it stands
to reason it's already been done before
us or that if we did in word of credit
it could have been created and we could
be in it so there's a there's a simple
mathematical form there's very little
differentiation between saying that um
it's saying that we're in a simulation
and it's all been created and saying
that there's a God identical I have to
point out this is Nietzsche's idea of
the Eternal recurrence by the way yeah
yeah what is that the same concept he
says look everything that's been done
has been done before and it occurred
exactly the same way well in the 90s we
just said everything was derivative yeah
yeah so what I say is it's not a
simulation it's an MMORPG what's that a
massive multiplayer online role-playing
game yeah yeah my son uh my son was
telling me the other day he thinks we're
living on the edge of the simulation and
I was like why do you think we're not in
the simulator relation to game yeah I
think it's like if it you know people
say simulation simulation and I'm like
right I don't know I think uh I'd put my
my bet on MMORPG meaning a large number
of people are players and a large number
of people are non-playing characters
that facilitate the existence of the
game actually the NPCs would explain a
lot exactly yeah I don't think that
there are any NPCs I think that does a
disservice to humanity and our
relationships have you seen this
recently I really listen animals are
non-player characters I understand why
you would think that there are
non-player characters of of human beings
but I think it really it I I don't think
it just does those people a disservice I
think it does us a disservice and our
understanding
moral argument doesn't change my
perspective on people being NPCs I don't
want to believe it well that's fine
they're not truly a non-human I want to
believe that everyone
I've seen this recent research that
about a third of human beings don't have
an inner monologue yeah
I don't understand that either that's
what I'm talking about and have you ever
seen the the test of mental imagery no
they show you they say which one when
you're told to think of an apple what do
you see and then they showed very
varying pictures of apples some people
can't visualize anything nor can they
think words in their own mind my son was
asking me the other day he was like mom
do you think in sentences like you're
talking to yourself and I was like yeah
and he was like yeah me too
monologue yeah some people don't have
one I used to whack you how do you how
do you go about life and figure out how
to make decisions if you're not
constantly in communication with you so
so I was uh reading this story a long
time ago and I was hanging up my friends
and I was reading and I was like whoa I
was like they're saying that a third of
people don't have an inner monologue and
then one of my friends said what's
what's an inner monologue and I said
like when you're thinking sometimes
you're you're you're thinking like
you're speaking almost like you're in
your mind you have a train of thought
that is various words and then my friend
was like I don't know what that I don't
know what that is well here's the other
thing too
I've had I've got multilingual friends
who explain their inner monologue
switches back and forth right because
they speak in different languages and
I'm like oh that's interesting and then
there's some people tell me they don't
have one and I asked my friend like then
what are you thinking and they're like
I don't know and I'm just like what
what's in your mind like do you see
pictures because the craziest thing for
me is you know when I do these videos
where I'm like just talking in a stream
of Consciousness right I'm actually on a
multi-track mindset sometimes when I'm
reading articles and talking I'm
imagining like I'm scheduling my day I'm
doing a bunch of things wow yeah so to
hear that some people don't even have a
single tract was like how do you
function is it like stimuli is it this
is why I think that um not not this
solely I don't think anyone everyone who
doesn't have an inner monologue as an
NPC but I think this is indicative of
the fact that some people are NPCs and
we talked about on this show there's
this I can't remember who brought it up
maybe you know what Ian the theory that
there's a finite number of Souls and
that there's too many humans on the
planet so not every person is in sold
that's horrifying that's a horrifying
thought yeah I think it's more of a
resolution to believe it but there's no
argument to to believe or disbelief I
think it's like a a resolution scaling
system where like I used to picture an
apple it was red round Apple but now I
picture like a highly refined I can see
the light shimmering off it when I
visualize it only because I've developed
my brain and my ability to by letting go
of my shame and stuff like that so I I
think it's not that they don't have it
it's that they can't really see it
because they don't understand what it is
but it's there communicating their
subconscious is constantly in
communication think about that if you
believe in the subconscious I'm a
skeptic on the subconscious do you
believe animals have souls no and so
this is an Orthodox Christian exactly a
typical Christian belief only humans
have souls right now
play a video game like uh GTA do animals
or no no Let's do let's do uh let's play
Skyrim okay do the animals just playing
that yesterday do the animals in that
game have souls no well nobody's
nobody's playing them there's no no one
is in control they just do this program
to based thing right now for a single
player game like Skyrim no one but you
has a soul because all the other thing
you know not an MMO you know that many
of these people that are running around
doing things these other players people
they're so they have souls there's a
player behind it but there are also
animals running around that have no soul
I look around at the planet and I look
at animals and I don't see them as
having Souls I like bucko I don't think
it's a soul how do you define a soul a
player character I do not think animals
are player characters you think they're
conscious
I think there's varying degrees of what
we Define as Consciousness but I do not
believe that animals have souls do you
think they're sentient
I well perhaps elephants and maybe
dolphins and some larger whales someone
was saying Jesus is alive Jesus Christ
is alive and I was like I think the what
you want to start saying is Jesus Christ
is sentient because his body died so
he's dead but his soul lives on in this
form of sentience this like field of
magnet of whatever it is if it's plasma
or something greater than that that's
still there interacting with us well in
Orthodoxy we reject The Ghost and the
Machine idea so we don't believe that a
soul and a body are separate things
so the way I have tried to describe this
would you say that you're like a
physical physicalist yes in a way
um the way I've tried to explain this to
secular people is you could look upon a
soul as a transmitter right and and the
software program that runs the hardware
that does the transmission is the soul
right but you could also look at the
soul as a receiver
there's a transmission
from God and your body is capable of
receiving this transmission and and and
understanding it and and even
interpreting it in certain ways and when
you die the signal doesn't go away
the signal doesn't stop that's what I'm
thinking I think so like you've got your
own magnetic field that's interpreting
the greater field and then that's why we
believe in bodily Resurrection
the body will be Resurrection otherwise
your soul wouldn't be resurrected
because we're embodied beings
I think about simulation theory in terms
of like video games and you were
mentioning there's no different Olivia
you mentioning there's no difference
between a simulation and saying it's
created and we've talked about this
before I completely agree so the world
is created do you think the world's
created created well I don't know but I
but I so I I I don't know agnostic for
the most part I'm not atheist though I
do believe in God but um created I guess
I guess a simple answer is yes and
perhaps the process of whatever what
whatever whether you're believing in
solid state Theory or Big Bang Theory
whatever you want to believe all of that
is the process of creation well it's
just transmutation nothing can ever be
created or destroyed that's what I when
I was teaching CCD at my church
um I had a kid come in and his mom was
making him go to it's like you know
catechism it's when you're when you're
uh preparing for confirmation which is
glad to hear that still goes on one of
the sacraments
um yeah and so his mom was making him go
and he was like I'm an atheist and I'm
like okay
like that's cool be an atheist uh and he
was like I don't believe in an afterlife
and I was like okay so you know
what about what about you know the that
energy can neither be created or
destroyed and he was like yeah okay I
believe in science and I was like okay
so what happens to your energy when you
die
and he was like I don't I don't know it
goes back into something and I'm like
right so it doesn't die right so your
energy in some form even in your
scientific atheist
um understanding of the world goes
somewhere it has to continue on with
that what's true that energy can be
created or destroyed I just we think it
can't be we think it can't be sure so uh
and he thought it couldn't be oh yeah
what's your favorite video game
um
I actually still like Skyrim especially
with the new updates I was just playing
it with some of the plugins Skyrim great
uh what's the White Run yeah that's one
of those main cities in the game did
anyone build those cities in the game
like when you go into the game and walk
up to the city did any of those
characters actually chop down the trees
and construct those buildings
uh no no they didn't it was it was
created by the creator of the even the
house I live in in White Run in the game
and but to the characters they're in
buildings that according to the lore
were created yeah so I think it's funny
when talking about simulation Theory
because the idea of a simulation versus
a constructed or intelligently designed
universe or a Creator yes is they're all
the same idea and then you consider this
dinosaurs and fossils when people say
they were always there I don't believe
that the Earth has been around that long
many secular individuals or atheists who
will laugh and say that's absurd we've
done carbon dating Etc and it's like yes
and just like a video game if we're in a
simulation they were drag and drop and
placed there for purposes of the game
for some reason when you have Christians
who say that that's that's what happened
with archaeological finds that they were
placed there to be part of those are
understandable like in the video game
the buildings are placed there and no
one built them there's an excellent book
called forbidden archeology
um there's a shorter paperback version
of it but it's just an analysis of about
1500 archaeological digs in which when
they do carbon dating humans have been
here way way longer
they actually correct carbon dating to
Accord with evolutionary theory even
though the physical evidence contradicts
it
and this happens a lot so like what I've
heard is if something's been exposed to
the air uh and you carbonate it it's
going to have a way later or I think a
later date right like we have these
famous Footprints in Texas
um where we have uh dinosaur footprints
it's dinosaur footprints they Park you
know and human Footprints are also there
dated to the same time someone was just
saying they can't be they say it can't
be because of evolutionary theory I
think it was Randall Carlson might have
said that two million years he thinks
humans have been around for two million
years yes why does it just keeps getting
older and older he didn't give any
evidence but aren't they also not
necessarily human beings like there are
all these other humanoids hominids yeah
yeah hominids that's the word that like
came before us like neanderthals and all
these different kinds of it's actually
nice you're overthinking it it's
actually much simpler life originated on
Venus but a runaway greenhouse effect
destroyed the planet so the last humans
of the planet was falling apart due to
greenhouse effect which led to you know
sulfuric acid rain built the arc project
which took the DNA from two of as many
animals as possible the military then
launched it before the planet was
destroyed and they came to Earth which
they had been terraforming for some
hundreds of thousands of years and you
know then disseminated the the genetics
to create life that was around the uh
the the the Precambrian area which is
why we see the percambrian explosion
that's when the arc project deposited
all the new animals because we needed to
now start colonizing Earth unfortunately
Venus was destroyed and now we can't go
back and check because the density of
the acid destroys our satellites and
probes in the land when I was a kid I
used to think that all of the planets
had been uh
um consecutively inhabited
and consecutively inhabited so Earth it
was Earth's turn Mars was had been
inhabited but it had lost its atmosphere
and so Mars was no longer inhabited
wouldn't that now it's earth like one by
one you know I was gonna say a great
movie because the great flood is on
Venus not on earth right and they I was
reading about how Venus may have once
had an Earth-like climate because it's a
relatively close enough to the Sun but a
run they do say a runaway greenhouse
effect caused sulfur you know acid
buildup which destroys everything and so
I'm like you know yeah we want fun ideas
when the sun was smaller it wasn't as
hot on Venus it just expanded and then
essentially cooked to the planets like
Venus they thought those were um like uh
compact uh comet impact all these
creators on Venus but now what they
think is that the planet got so hot that
it it cooked and exploded out all this
goo out of itself basically baked and
then exploded right because of the Sun
but the reason I think that life
originated on Earth in this solar system
is because of the Moon because this
weird moon like Thea smashed into Earth
four billion years ago came out ball of
magma that cools down into this Moon
that pulls on the tides and causes for
all this unique gestation of life that's
not what happened what happened was when
Earth was forming God clicked and
dragged and dropped the moon and then
typed in the parameters for stable
gravitation and that's why the moon and
the sun line up perfectly creating an
eclipse and then put a whole bunch of
water on the planet yeah for them for
the moon to measure well physicists
recognize for the moon to mess with I
mean I get in conflicts with physics all
the time because being math guy you know
we don't trust the existence of their
abstract math entities and they believe
these things exist sometimes so but they
they have this idea of this what do they
call it the strong anthropomorphic
principle that the Universe does appear
to have been designed for physicists to
understand it
I love it and they don't know what to
call it you know all these constants
could have been all these different ways
depending on how the big bang went but
they all fell this way that human
consciousness could figure it out
and they call there's a strong and a
weak version of that principle is it a
joke no it's serious because I mean I
think people developed sensors to be
able to read the universe that's why we
are sensors or at the very least we're
only having these conversations because
we developed the ability to understand
the universe yes otherwise we'd be
rabbits running around just because each
other well that would be the Garden of
Eden right I mean when people talk about
how the the Fall From Grace and the
Garden of Eden I'm always like I'm super
grateful for that otherwise we would
actually not be the conscious beings
that we are it's like a you know
discussion of how human beings became
conscious I was recently listening to a
podcast about the theory of evolution
and how when Darwin came out with his
theory
um what happened was it was broadly
accepted relatively quickly and all
other theories about the you know
origins of mankind were just tossed out
as fake
interesting I wonder if he knew somebody
yeah I wonder about that as well like
how did this Theory uh how did it how
did it explode and become the only
theory that we consider you know the
worst religion would be what's that that
we're in a video game and when you die
you wake up at Dave and Buster's like
Blitz and and you're like and
you're like out of chips on your card
exactly you're like like Rick and Morty
the Roy game right right it's like you
just wake up and everyone's like that
was a pretty good run what did you do
you were a editor-in-chief for a
Independent Media Outlet
I always thought kodan's religion was
interesting you know he worshiped krom
the god of strength and if you're ever
weak enough to have to call on his Aid
he would kill you anyway
they're like in a Klingon religion and
the Klingon Warriors killed all of the
Gods hundreds of years ago
what what is your trade like you're
saying you're a math guy yeah what is
your main like studies and and I was
straight as a topologist
um but you can't feed a family on that
so I do statistics like most people
which leads me into AI but I'm more
interested in topology meaning like the
study of the Earth's surface no no uh to
oh man that's a way to explain so
there's a set theoretic definition of
this but that will not be helpful okay
so imagine that you have a you have a
geometry it could be euclidean geometry
whatever
you have a geometry and you take out the
ability to measure distance
all right
so now you could think of everything is
infinitely stretchy there's no concept
of distance relationships well in that
kind of a scheme a circle and a square
and a triangle are all the same shape
right because you can stretch them into
the same shape
so instead of using a congruence
relation like you would in basically you
could Define branches of mathematics by
their identity relations right so a
congruence relation in a geometry says
if you overlay the two objects they have
the same exact outline right right in
algebra equality is the identity
relation it has to be the exact same
number
a homeomorphism is the identity relation
to topology and it's basically can they
be stretched into the same shape wow
real real quick a lot of science a lot
of people are have been mentioning
throughout the show that the balloon
exploded over Montana well really we
didn't bring it up because as much as
I'm checking all we have is a video and
it is confirmed well it's not confirmed
but is reportedly BS yeah because I
thought it was actually moving East I
thought it was over Missouri at this
point so uh there's a video going viral
showing something coming down and
everyone's saying explosion explosion
this is it and uh Ryan savedra says
video is likely totally totally BS
billing says we're not aware of an
explosions and defense officials tell uh
Fox News the balloon over Montana has
not been exploded was not shot down by
videos and videos are fake yep and it's
still over Montana well it's moving no
it's moving East and apparently for some
reason and for some reason the Pentagon
is just letting it move East I mean it's
it's so humiliating like
I feel humiliated by our government that
they're just letting this happen like
blow this thing up
I want them to capture just take it down
I was thinking what happens is the
Chinese were running a border scan
across the southern Canadian border now
I was talking about shirts Chinese I
mean yeah no yeah it is China said it
was there it's theirs they just said it
was a civilian they said don't worry
about it you guys it's totally fine that
we're doing this anyway we let it stay
up there it makes no sense it is
humiliating like they gotta at least
bring it down and study it
um I'm so I have so little faith in this
government I'm just like I'm chilling
what's that a psyop though could it be
ours and they're just saying no no China
released an official statement saying
it's a Chinese civilian aircraft that
appeared off course but that could be a
joint declaration by the US government
and the Chinese government you know the
dod has 1.9 trillion dollar budget and
we can't take we can't take down a
balloon we can that's the thing but we
won't a drone one point
I think there was confusions because it
said it's over Mo the state Mo which is
Missouri Missouri but it's that's in the
other side of the world
it's going east it's moving East it's a
balloon it travels
Missouri's got South Dakota Nebraska and
Iowa between Montana it moved the Jets
through Missouri it's in Missouri now
yeah I thought it was in high
atmospheric orbit I thought it was like
80 000 feet yeah something super high
and I guess they said that it was moving
towards the center of the country that's
what the Pentagon they said it was
moving East yeah it's the jet stream
that's that's what happens you know this
makes me remember Japan in World War II
those bombs they built balloon bombs
yeah I mean this would be a way to
deliver us you know a large huge
explosive I watched well or some
documentary or like the things
some little kids in like the 80s found
an unexploded bomb and they like hit it
with a rock and it blew up and what had
happened is they explained how Japan
would make these balloons that had a
mechanism for when they got hot and got
too high then uh it would like release
pressure
but then if it got too low a bag would
fall off and it would go back up and it
would make it across the jet stream and
start dropping bombs on the United
States yeah crazy it makes me remember
that they found uh kids after World War
II in um England found unexploded
ordinance it was always an issue
I'm so concerned about this balloon but
not go balloon bomb not the balloon
itself it's the behavioral response to
having a Chinese spy balloon yes that's
the concern that's the concern why are
we not doing anything why is the
government just like hey it's so it
doesn't make sense it's totally cool
that we have this spy balloon and you
know what else the Pentagon said the
Pentagon said um you know China already
has spy satellites so there's nothing
that they can see now that they haven't
been able to see with the spy satellite
no they built 9 300 of these these of
the ones that made it to the US only six
people were killed by them they were
extremely ineffective wow yeah they just
didn't work wow they probably had no
guidance mechanism right it's just
random the jet stream so bombed Oregon I
guess but this Chinese balloon probably
has some way to guide well this Chinese
balloon also is giving China a whole lot
of information about how stupid we are
and we don't respond to anything it's
like here's a major threat we're not
going to respond to it at all a lot of
people are saying because they have low
Earth satellites this isn't that big of
a deal but like how do you know that you
need to break that thing part and look
at the Nano structure of the materials
used to build it it could be sensors it
could be all these sensors
even symbolically like get the
get it up yeah it makes me want to get a
gun yeah protect myself in case the
Chinese hit another balloon over my
house yes we should all have like what
RPGs take this it's not going to make a
thing down there's like this whole you
need to set up another balloon another
balloon to take it down to be able to
get that high up what 80 000 feet or
whatever High atmospheric uh we have
people who do that like we have those
guys who go all the way up to the top of
the you know way above the atmosphere
and they jump off platforms
all right we have one guy and it's
really dangerous because obviously it's
dangerous yeah it starts training you
can't stop right and there's no wind
then you're done what are we saying
about the structure of it you're saying
something bothers you about the
structure of this well look I mean
there's a pattern here like we don't
protect our Southern border right we we
know we could interdict all these drugs
we don't right we can drone people all
over the Middle East but we can't drone
drug drug dealers in Mexico
um we're now we're not protecting our
airspace
from just blatant intrusion by Chinese
spy balloons we have an incredibly old
daughtery man it doesn't seem to care at
all yeah there's just like a whole
program here I I actually don't believe
that the president's in control of the
military ever since Trump trump is what
proved that to me right well I really
don't even look at Paul because Trump
tried to pull our troops out of Syria do
it yeah you've been on small things they
they refused he ordered military parades
every year of his presidency and they
refused to do it I would have loved to
see a military parade that would have
been bad enough I know Millie actually
gave him the middle finger and put a
tank
out there and just let it sit there wow
I mean they literally gave him the
middle finger I was heard that Biden
wanted to shoot it down and gave the or
I don't know if he gave the order no but
he wanted to Pentagon said no Pentagon
said not a good idea Biden was asked
about it when he was talking about some
garbage stupid thing that he's got
planned right now and uh instead he just
looked at the reporters and walked out
the room it's so strange how we give
China in some ways we're so militant
towards China by rhetoric well we can't
decide if they're competitors enemies or
Allies
just never do anything
it's odd meanwhile they have uh China
said that their military needs to be
ready by what was it 2027 to invade
Taiwan
and Biden has said that we will
militarily defend Taiwan
so now we're we're literally looking at
in our lifetimes a two-front war against
China and Russia this is a disastrous
situation I mean if Obama was talking
about the managed decline of the United
States this is the managed destruction
of the United States it's not even a
decline okay let's just destroy
ourselves I called it this with uh and I
I did a video leading with Jack
pesobic's story about how his
neighborhood fell apart it's a slow
motion control demolition we've said it
yeah I love that I love that yeah well I
I I I get the vibe that the Chinese are
terrified we're going to invade them and
this so they're like if they invade us
we need to know what their northern
border is secured light because we'll
have to send troops through Canada we
can't we're not an invasive Force we
don't have the ground troops for an
invasion and we also don't have the base
right the United States is an air
superiority military that's how we win
so we've got missiles exactly right what
they're concerned about is Taiwan there
I think they're getting ready to invade
Taiwan that's why we just put a bunch of
we're putting a bunch of stuff in the
Philippines and and I think these
balloons most likely are they need as
much data as possible and so it you know
there's a lot of questions like why
aren't they using satellites satellites
have to keep moving for the most part I
mean there's geostationary orbit yeah
this is going very slowly they have to
crisscross to be able to track different
areas this balloon can move around and I
think
most likely
like I said yesterday and on my shoulder
earlier the guy robbing a liquor store
doesn't care that he has a gun illegally
because he's already planning on
committing a greater crime in robbing a
liquor store right China doesn't care if
we're mad about a balloon they're
already planning something that's going
to piss us off so screw it well there's
there's all kinds of ways of doing
reconnaissance like their satellites
could be looking at all of our
electronic emissions trying to detect
the balloon
and learning all about our electronic
detection systems this is the kind of
stuff that goes on right yeah
yeah the Russians are actually masters
of that you want to be like almost like
oops we accidentally pulled the balloon
down somehow I just shoot it down just
shoot them well shoot it down then you
got no way they can't
so I have experience 80 000 feet and
it's not something where it's just like
dispatch X to go do it you need to ASAP
missile yeah right you need an
anti-satellite missile to get it yep
it's too high for a jet so what do you
do another balloon yeah another balloon
carrying a bunch of blades or something
listen if we have a 1.9 trillion dollar
defense budget and we can't take down a
balloon
it's that we can't deploy anything right
no I understand that so we have to build
it which you can't just do instantly
well that's dumb and we've outsourced
all of our production to China yeah can
you build an anti-balloon
I mean Trump at least was like trying to
get drug manufacturing back in the U.S
he was trying to convert what was it the
Kodak Factory up in Rochester to turn it
into like uh what was it like for lasers
for ibuprofen or whatever lasers could
take it down people are pointing out but
um you still have to get within a
certain range for the laser to be
effective I mean eighty thousand feet
it's a long ways that's a long way for a
laser so but maybe they could get uh
halfway up with some kind of high
altitude drone and then and they do have
those supposedly we have ASAP missiles
that can shoot satellites I don't know
if there's a laser that can do they work
maybe I'm actually skeptical that a lot
of our technology works I agree our
triple seven artillery very simple
machine it's just absolutely inferior to
Russian Artillery the Ukraine conflict
has approved that right that and um I
think a lot of stuff is made to enrich
the defense companies
but also as Ukraine's war was to line
the pockets of the people 100 icbms are
in disrepair yeah yeah so and yet
Russians have Hypersonic missiles that
we know have they've launched in Ukraine
and work
and they're they're 100 stealthy and
undetectable by radar because of the
plasma that that develops in front of
them oh awesome so they're stealthy and
Hypersonic and our cities are just
really vulnerable
and they're shooting what 64 000 I think
was what Conor McGregor was saying 64
000 artillery rounds a day wow and
they're going to blow up all our tanks
and Ukraine can barely muster 5 000 and
they've wiped out the artillery round
stores for all the NATO countries like
we're not we're not industrially
prepared for war anymore no we're not
it's ridiculous that yeah yeah Russia
knows done a very poor job so does China
yeah and I think there's uh something to
be said for Innovation you know there's
an old saying in manufacturing that
Innovation happens on the shop floor so
when you Outsource manufacturing The
Innovation goes over there
because it's from solving real world
problems that you learn how to innovate
the Russians have never outsourced and
the sanctions paradoxically forced them
to develop their own internal Industries
which I think bolstered internal
Innovation well and China outsources but
only for uh the purpose of gathering
resources 100 I was thinking about
France and World War II because they
were like the superpower on Earth next
to Germany and Japan right and then they
were just taken off the table in the
early days of the war like if the United
States if China were to invade the
United States in like three weeks with
tactical Nuclear strikes on the coastal
cities and invasion of the capital thing
is we can work decentially now so it's
it's a lot harder to to nullify a
country by taking the capital but like
we think like if there was a world war
between the United States and like the
United States could be removed from the
game in the first days if you're if
we're stupid I mean land Warfare we I
don't I don't actually think the NATO
alliance could possibly beat Russia we
don't have enough guys yeah in Naval and
land Warfare land we just don't have
enough stuff but I don't think the
Ukraine thing is attacking Russia that's
what I differ from a lot of my friends
on the right they think that we're
trying to attack I think we're trying to
destroy Germany
oh like they're trying to bankrupt and
Destroy Germany like they were doing to
de-industrialize Germany which was the
program in World War one and World War
II yeah but then we paid to rebuild them
yeah we did so why would we want to
corrupt our investment at this point for
the same reason World War One started we
will not allow a an alliance between
Germany and Russia you mean it wasn't
Archduke Ferdinand yeah the British you
mean killed by the Black Hand Society
Finance by the British Foreign Service
sure yeah
uh but the the mckinder thesis you can
look that up but it's a long-running
um sort of foreign policy idea a British
foreign policy idea that there are land
peoples and sea peoples
and uh anglosphere foreign policy has
been completely directed toward
prevention of an alliance between Europe
and Russia
so there's always got to be and and so
the the Nordstrom pipelines directly
threatened that it was creating an
alliance between Germany and Russia wow
and and Russia was actively attempting
to come into the Western economy they
were they were they were moving away
from China into the Western economy
um and uh Anglo foreign policy cannot
allow that
um and has historically literally since
the 1600s been completely directed at
preventing that that's what world war
one was actually about
it was and so we we're literally
de-industrializing Germany with high
energy costs right now
yeah and we killed that whole pipeline
we're also destroying um England with
the high energy costs yes we are
more people freeze every year because of
extreme temperatures than die of any
kind of heat exposure
all right let's go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
and become a member at timcast.com to
support our work and you get access to a
massive library of uncensored members
only shows and support our cultural
Endeavors but let's uh read what you
guys have to say we got JTV Scott says
release the code meaning your entire
network of influencers Ian has the most
honest roles
oh very nice hey
so we have a lot of comments early on
where people are saying it looked like
the balloon was shot down but it's I see
yeah not not seems to be not the case
all right let's see
okay Alex says this man's story is
extremely important and needs to get out
meanwhile the chat is spammed with Eliza
blue nonsense respect the quartering but
y'all need a life well you know it is
what it is we're here to talk about uh
Jeff's story Matthew Whit says I've been
trying to tell people about Jeff younger
but all the Liberals tell me I'm lying
or the mother has the right to do that
I'm sorry for the situation I would be
mortified yeah what is the next on the
horizon now for you legally
um they're they're going to push me into
an early trial as soon as they can the
judge will probably clear the docket and
let it get done because they want to get
this trial done before Texas passes a
law requiring parental consent
and then what will happen after that it
will happen probably I'm guessing right
at the six month Mark is how the judge
will do it and then uh it's possible for
the California courts to take over
jurisdiction since she will have lived
there for six months and then my kids
fall under California laws but if Texas
passes the law that gives both parents
I'm going to try again to get an order
to have them return to Texas and give me
emergency jurisdiction over them
all right here's one this is actually
seemingly insulting but also actually
kind of um respectful Zach Harrington
says Ian's willingness to say things
that would embarrass a normal person is
absolutely inspiring but actually I
think that's a compliment it is so key
because I agree there are a lot of
people that should say something but are
worried about what other people think
and won't say it and uh Ian will say
what he thinks he will it's freeing too
like they laugh at first and it's like
oh I hurt I hurt but then eventually you
realize like they don't laugh as much
anymore
um
all right Stephen says ask Jeff if he
ever considered getting a bishop or
priest to do an exorcism on his wife
um well we converted into Orthodoxy and
prior to conversion we went through an
exorcism uh and then at baptism another
exorcism
and then when my sons were born we have
a what's called a churching period so
the children and the mother are not
allowed in church for 40 days and then
they comment are exercised and brought
into the body after 40 days so that's
three of them what was The Exorcism like
um the prayers of exorcism uh one uh
require that you uh spit on the devil's
name you literally spit to the West
um and um that's to determine if you're
under his influence and they ask for the
Holy Spirit to remove any infernal
influence and it's it's a it's prayed
the exorcism prayers are Prayed by the
entire church do people cry sometimes
yeah it's like you're literally
exercising the soul yeah yeah but you
know Orthodoxy is somewhat different
than Roman Catholicism in that we do not
uh generally approve of moving the
passions in church
so yeah Blue Collar Henry says this is
exact the exact reason mgtow exists no
marriage until Law changes Well yeah if
you go to my Twitter feed you'll see
that I was swarmed by feminists when I
suggested that men
uh may have to start using surrogacy and
adoption if they want to have children
and a lot of conservatives and religious
people are really mad at me right now
and feminine Abomination and it's it's a
surrogacy should be entirely illegal
commercial surrogacy
yes it's not someone else no it's when
you rent a woman's body yeah they're
full of drugs and then take her baby
once it's born yes brutal I call it
pre-adoption so I don't think it's as
bad it's extremely well you've never
been pregnant I mean I could not imagine
it's absolutely it's someone else's AG
the woman is hosting someone else's egg
yes usually which also in order to host
someone else's egg you have to take
drugs to prevent um or organ rejection
the same kind of drugs that you would to
do that you have to go through IVF drugs
I mean it's like it's an insane process
and it's very much like prostitution
except you're getting screwed for nine
months but unfortunately it's the only
way for fathers to be secure in their
posterity under the law there's
absolutely no reason I think we should
change the law there's absolutely no
reason that women should be subjected to
men's whims and have their bodies forced
to uh Force into that for money there's
there's absolutely
it's consensual if they're it is getting
money ideally I mean I agree no one
should be forced sure it's consensual to
buy women yeah you can buy women with
money you can definitely do that you can
you can definitely do it but that
doesn't make it right and it certainly
doesn't make it something that should be
legally sanctioned
but are you as opposed to the single
single motherhood uh I'm I'm as opposed
to single motherhood by choice where you
would get a sperm donor and do that I'm
100 opposed to that what about getting
pregnant naturally but uh not getting
married or rejecting the father those
kinds of things I don't think that's
great I don't think that's a great
situation but if you get pregnant and
you keep your child you know and you do
right by your child I'm in favor of that
all right Patriots says I sympathize
with Jeff I went through the same thing
with two daughters and a drug abusing
ex-wife who'd have gang members dealers
and drugs caught on tape leaving them
for hours and Drug deals with them
present berated by judges for suing for
full custody yeah in general because of
the money interest I told you about
title 4D the family courts generally
give the child to the dysfunctional
parent because the the responsible
parent will pay and make money the drug
dealer will never pay the child support
and they'll never get the money so they
tend to give the child to the
dysfunctional parent and the functional
parent will pay is that only if the
dysfunction what happens to be a woman
no no no no no no no there's there's
tons of others this has happened to in
Texas believe me I had custody of myself
awarded to my father
so I was raised by my father
and then I had custody awarded to his
ex-wife who was not my mother you did
that by choice no no it all got very
screwed up the whole thing was very
crazy but I mean I've been through so
many divorce processes at this point
yeah in Texas the stats are that in a
divorce
this isn't General this is of divorce
couples
94.3 percent of the time the father will
get every other weekend
it's largely a father problem but
increasingly it is affecting mothers as
mothers as as men become less
responsible mothers become the more
responsible party so the court says
she'll be the one to pay child what the
heck that makes no sense that you would
give the kid to the less responsible
parent it doesn't for the child's
benefit but it does for the state
budgets and at that point don't the
people have a duty to step up and tell
the state you've gone wrong every time I
stand up and talk about the problem of
single motherhood and the problem the
way that the child support industry
promotes it
uh Republican women go absolutely insane
on me they go insane on me it is not a
popular topic even among Republicans
what is it specifically that they go
insane they say you're anti-woman
somehow because you're for traditional
marriage like I want to get rid of
no-fault divorce I I think you should be
you should be able to get divorced if
the five faults one of the five faults
are present
but no fault divorce needs to go away if
if you want to date someone date someone
if you want to get married correct or
something different and the the
arrangement outside of marriage should
be 50 50 custody no child support
unless one of the parents is unfit which
has happened what are the five faults uh
abandonment uh denial of affection which
is basically you don't have sex right
fraud
um what would fraud be like you have
another family yeah bigamy would be one
bigamy would be a form of fraud
um uh it's widely uh hiding money and
resources and stuff well or it could go
the other way it could be that you say
that you have more money than you did or
whatever you you tempted someone to
marry you under a lie I see
um uh abuse and then neglect
abandonment abandoned abandonment that's
different than neglected you said you
said that already yeah
abandonment yeah go through those again
okay so maybe let's see if I got this
right so we got um let's go with
infidelity there you go infidelity yeah
infidelity fraud
um abuse abandonment and denial of
affection
denial of affection I love yeah no you
have a right to sex and marriage and
that's we prior to no fault divorce you
had a right to that wow yeah all right
let's see we got mcchilla says a man has
to be absolutely insane these days to
get married in the U.S I agree many
would caution against even cohabitation
due to common law marriage I agree wise
up man mgtow free top G repeal the 19th
you know what it is common law is not
real though like people misunderstand
common law it's not it's not a real
thing what is it it's this urban legend
that if you live with Owen for a long
enough period of time you are now
legally married but that's just not real
that's not true Texas does have a common
law statute
but it requires that you represent
yourself as married three times in
public until you're married yeah and
it's because you are choosing you look
like you represent yourself the idea is
you say you're married oh you say the
idea is you're inadvertently married and
you go oh no now I'm married because we
lived together we were roommates oh
Jesus that's how it works that doesn't
work you have to assert your marriage
you have to file claims against your
marriage and then for some amount of
time you can legally seek benefits but
if you don't then then you you won't
yeah but living with a woman could still
be very dangerous because you have no
rights if you're not married and you
have a child your rights are even worse
if you're not married so
all right lacuba says deadlifts are
great for grip strength Ian look into
the starting strength program it's great
for beginners also when Luke comes back
you should try to get the program's
founder mark ripito on yeah Mark's cool
guy cool yeah thanks
all right Alex shot says just think not
too long ago the biggest peer pressure
kids had to worry about was hey kids you
want to go smoke and get drunk now it's
hey kids you want to take hormone
blockers and cut off your junk yep and
the schools are pushing it that's the
difference the schools were against
drugs but the schools are all pushing
this
they're not scary for these a lot of
these kids you know you look at these D
transitioners these kids are going to
grow up and it's going to be really
horrifying yes it is it's already
horrifying if you've met any of them
people in touch with Chloe Cole no I I
have online I have online and then but I
have good friends of mine in Texas Who
are the transitioners they already are
yeah transitioning yes yeah in fact if
have you guys seen the video of me at
UNT when antifa attacked me with Kelly
knighter right yeah yeah I talked to
Kelly about that she's terrified she was
like locked in a closet for a while yes
yes wow I got a rib broken whoa the guy
tried to choke me out they wouldn't let
you speak at all did you did you end up
saying it speaking at all yeah they
eventually so because I'm not like these
these limp wrist ignore me conservatives
so antifa shows up right I'm like okay I
got an hour and a half I'm gonna make
you yell for an hour and a half go for
it and I had a microphone so I could
always go louder than them so I was like
is this all you kami's got the yellow
the red guards are better than you guys
so they got all pissed and then they
they were worn out after about half an
hour you just can only Bank tables and
yell for so long and then one of the
shot callers from antifa there's always
a shot caller right the shot caller
comes over
and he stupidly posted this on YouTube
The Shot Caller posted all of his radio
radio and chat comments to all the other
guys it's funny he comes over and says
you know what this guy's doing he's
making us look stupid by making us chant
like this we probably should let him
talk so then I started my talk and then
they surrounded the building with about
400 people whoa
three or four hundred and then they
threatened to burn the building down and
then the police evacuated Nazis yeah
Neil comes yeah some guy got a good shot
of me the cop put my head down and then
somebody I don't know if it was a knee
or but a guy broke my rib on my right
side
guy tried to choke me I had to Gable
grip out of it were you like there
taking you through a crowd or something
yeah to get to a police car this was all
because you're trying to protect your
children yeah yeah that's it I actually
always because you're screaming at the
crowd I was running for political office
in Texas I was running to be a member of
the Texas house and Kelly knighter's
organization the young young
conservatives of Texas invited me to
come speak about my campaign
and that because of the anti-tran stuff
so I'm like on the top 10 list for
antifa in Texas like when I go to the
Capitol they have armed people follow me
around you know and people are all like
you should move to Texas you should move
to Florida I'm like dude West Virginia
is Michael country yes so I have to I
have to say this because we we've got
people who issue threats and stuff
if they came out to the mountains of
West Virginia
um my warning to them is like please
don't because we don't want you to get
hurt right like I'm just saying you're
going to come to some mountain and
there's going to be some right-wing nut
job with you know an AR on each shoulder
and pistols on each you know all over
his body and he's gonna be yelling
Yeehaw as he sees him about rolling up
like don't do it don't come out here man
yeah you know it's like antifa's all
over the urban areas of Texas yeah you
come out here and uh nope well here's a
post on social media scare me the fact
that our team the posts where they're
like I hope they come here it would be
awesome my day and I'm like no guys you
you don't want to hurt like we don't
want anybody getting hurt we don't want
anything for showing up because then
they're gonna be leaving in body bags
and that's bad bad bad do not come out
here ain't nobody out here is gonna
tolerate that and we've seen these
videos from a few years ago where like
antifa up to a residential neighborhood
and it was in a suburban area and then
people came out of their houses and you
saw it was like it was like Union guys
yes and they just started shoving them
and pushing them then you see videos
where I was in West Virginia no no no no
just some suburb I can't remember where
it was but they're pushing on the
antifa's like stop stop man leave us
alone yeah they can get away with us in
cities where the police Run cover for
them that's what I was gonna say but you
come out into the countryside where you
walk onto someone's property with a
weapon and self-defense and castle
doctrine kick in real quick please do
not come out here well they didn't in
Missouri with uh they didn't in Missouri
with that couple that stood out that was
in St Louis yeah that's St Louis the
police protect antifa they do that's
right yeah John Tifa only operate in
permissive environments and so that
tells you a lot about the political
structures where you live so I live in
Denton County Texas in a town called
Flower Mound
and it's it's very instructive that they
will not operate in flower Mounds but
they will operate in Denton the city
which is in Denton County because the
sheriff is permissive yep and the police
chief in Denton is permissive that's
that's all you need to know about your
elected officials in law enforcement is
if antifa operates there they're
allowing it yep hands down because it's
uh no surprise they don't operate out
here yeah yeah because the cops out here
they're not actually like far right or
anything we've worked on them because of
the threats that we've gotten and
they're just kind of regular dudes yeah
but they don't tolerate it but more
importantly the attitude out here is
kind of like well you know it's West
Virginia it's constitutional carry and
if someone shows up and there's a pres a
threat to someone's life they have right
to defend themselves and their property
that's why I'm like I'm I'm actually
worried for these people if they came
out to the mountain because
you look at these these these message
boards for the neighborhood and it's
just people salivating being like
make my day right you know and I'm like
if it only stepped over the line yep I
could have got him yeah don't come out
here man but that's why it's like you
know Texas I wouldn't want to I wouldn't
want to go I don't want to go to a dense
Urban environment yeah where I have to
rely on Cops I'd rather be in my
constitutional carry state we have
security guards we have armed stuff but
we have we have laws that allow us to
defend ourselves and you have neighbors
who don't take kindly to people from the
from driving all the way out here far
left you know sure Wing nuts sure yeah
nut jobs I love it
all right agamemnon's gym bag says we're
literally living in the plot of 99 Red
Balloons but all I care about is your
son's welfare Jeff I'm not a praying man
but you have my prayers tonight
Luckenbach is no longer a destination to
move to yeah yeah Texas is Texas is a
very conservative population that is
ruled by extremely left-wing Republicans
was it always like that in the last
decade pretty much the people forget
until the mid 90s uh Democrats ran Texas
it was a Democrat State until the mid
90s California was Republican to what
the 80s yeah all they did in Texas is
they switched from being Democrats to
being Republicans and they run as a
republican but they're still liberal
yeah did anyone else have 99 red left
balloons running through your head yeah
Sean says ATF has begun a 120-day
amnesty period to register your braced
pistols and wave the 200 tax if caught
with a braced pistol after 120 days
you'll be fined 250 000 and sentenced 10
years in prison uh I'm pretty sure the
ATF does not have legislative powers so
this is completely unconstitutional and
will likely be overturned very quickly
after the volley of lawsuits fired off
by every single gun rights organization
so uh you know we'll see I have a
feeling this is going to get shot down
in the court in an emergency injunction
within a matter of a week but we'll see
to stress the ATF can't decree
legislation that you will go to prison
for a thing that was not made illegal by
Congress so good luck right
but you don't take it seriously because
I'm not saying the government ain't
corrupt they certainly are they'll
certainly try
all right what do we got here grab some
more uh Dusty Firebirds as Libya is a
rock star Thank You For Fighting For
Kids Mr younger this episode is why I
watch every night I film birds in exotic
locations follow me if you love nature
too very cool what's the name Dusty
Firebird Dusty Firebird yeah
all right where are we at
a lot of people mentioning the massive
explosion in Billings Montana
um but what I could see is uh is
probably probably nothing you know
all right Guardsman norheim of the
teneth first says Tim's voice didn't
work in the Deep fake because he's not
an NPC already programmed in the machine
you know I don't know but I will say
this
um I have been told
by comedians it's hard to impersonate me
interesting Sheamus tried I think
Sheamus is trying something from Freedom
tunes and he's like I didn't I couldn't
figure out how to like get Tim who I
don't know like someone asked him on the
show I think can you do a Tim pool voice
and he's like I don't know how to figure
it out and I've heard that interesting I
don't know that's just me
wow Joe Rogan is also really hard to
impersonate people like look Trump is is
moderately difficult but people nail
Trump Tom Cruise pretty easy to get Ian
McKellen is easy like you know you can
you can nail these impersonations uh Dr
fauci I think is pretty easy but uh Dr
fauci has the same accent as my
grandmother did yeah yeah he's fairly
easy but there Joe Rogan has a weird
voice Brooklyn yes yeah there's a if you
ever if you ever notice this like a lot
of parodies with Joe Rogan will just get
nowhere near sounding like him it's a
weird yeah he's always posting um on
Instagram pictures of tattoos people get
of his face
like what is the deal that's the
weirdest thing he didn't post at first I
think he was weirded out and then he was
like you know what I'm just accepting my
life yeah wow this is real and some of
them are wild some of them have like a
third eye
all right the pool Sheriff says you'll
have to buy an official character in The
metaverse so people know it's you and
your truth will not uh not some fake
kind of like a blue check mark well I
think what it'll be like is there will
be the default avatars the poor people
will have where there's like seven
models and they all look the same but
with like different colors and then
there'll be the premium models that cost
you know 15 bucks a month or whatever
and then everyone will subscribe and or
you'll be able to rent your premium
clothing in the game just by spending
time in the game in the game there will
be chickens skins if you spend 40 hours
a week if you live and work in the
metaverse there's no crime there's no
theft no one can mug you you have no
fear of violence or anything like no
idea what's happening to your actual
body no you're in the Pod it's locked oh
you're in the line it could also be a
three deprivation they could also do it
as augmented Rachel's versus the
machines did you see that movie that's
actually a good have you seen surrogates
no Bruce Willis you've seen it yeah
everybody has a surrogate robot version
of themselves they don't leave their
houses they go in pods that control the
robot and the robot goes and does
everything oh I had a friend of mine who
was who's severely disabled who was
telling me that he really wanted one of
those well it's like an avatar the dude
was paralyzed so he got to be the you
know the movie did a good job of
presenting the creepiness of the robots
though the robots were cool right in
that movie yeah plastic looking yes and
then there's the scene where it's like
the hot chick is making out the guy yes
and then gets killed and they're like
let's go find the operator and the
operator is like a 400 pound morbidly
obese guy right yeah that's that's the
future if we go sir I think it'll be
metaverse like building complex Androids
seems like
easier yeah yeah but nobody has legs in
the middle of Earth right now oh really
I haven't I haven't really checked it
out yeah there was I don't I've never
gone in the metaverse or used the
metaverse how you pronounce it or
describe it but uh there's no legs we
really need people to float around
treadmills yeah VR treadmills where you
strap into like a bouncy they have a
harness yeah but they're not quite good
enough I want smooth feet where I can
run full speed
yeah but they're not I haven't found a
really good if you guys have a good one
you tell me the one with the bowl is it
I don't know it's got It's got a it's a
bowl that's a touch screen and you're
wearing a waste harness that goes around
your waist and you run and when you run
your character moves I was at VidCon
seven years ago and they had it set up
and people were playing an FPS uh a
first person shooter and you're watching
these people in these pods up high and
they're running full speed strapped in
and then going like this and shooting at
each other I've seen a lot of them but
they're they're only running like they
can't have a full gate like they can't
because the the bases aren't that big
once you can get it big enough where you
can run full speed a jump and have a
tread land without hurting yourself they
have a treadmill that moves in all
directions that you can run on dude and
then you get haptic feedback shirt
gloves you can feel stuff hitting you
it's gonna be so good and you can feel
exercise feel other things too right you
sure can this sounds like and you can
swim like if you can go like prone and
like swim kind of like where you're held
but then you got gravity that's a big
part of it is the underwater stuff is
hard to mimic right now right I think we
need to bring back appreciation for the
real world
yeah I'd say go to a boxing ring do
something real I'm not gonna do that but
all right someone someone in the chat
said that metaverse Graphics is like PS2
yes it's not good and it's because the
lenses are high resolution but super
zoomed in so it can work so we need to
get to like you know 16k resolution
before it starts becoming you know
better did any of you do second life
have you ever been in second I remember
I played that one time for a little bit
and I just kind of whatever I watched
some gameplay footage of it I bought
some land in in Second Life and and had
a server in it for a while I was
experimenting with it uh there were some
universities that had put up like
University areas where they were like
actually doing lectures and stuff
um it it actually looks better than the
metaverse I had some friends who were
Italian Architects and they were
obsessed with second life because you
could build stuff in there yeah yeah I
just I used to play World of Warcraft
and I I will tell you this night elf uh
human Rogue human Rogue night off Druid
what about you night off Druid oh yeah
dude most powerful in the whole world so
versatile yes well the first Telly was
good paladins are good too yeah they're
amazing you know what you know what I I
think they're a little overpowered what
I always found funny was that like when
I would play Rogue and do PVP I had no
problem you guys anybody pissed me off
but people would complain that warriors
were too strong and Rogues couldn't
couldn't kill them so they patch it and
make Rogues stronger and I'm just like
this is the most ridiculous thing ever
just because these people didn't know
how to play right but what happens is
Blizzard keeps going in and seeing like
well we gave them the tools to play the
character properly but they couldn't
figure it out so they're not having fun
so we better change the game to make it
fun right it's made it easier oh it was
roads are so deadly I remember standing
out with my night out shooting out
arrows you know to catch them catch
their invisibility and they're like
aiming randomly just aiming randomly
because I don't know where they are and
they just keep backstabbing me and see
vanilla was the best with preparation
because then you'd like the the bleeds
so like I never had a problem with
Warriors you would just like you go up
your garage you Hemorrhage Hemorrhage
you bleed then you vanish yeah then you
cut then you just then you just wait so
you wait as the Warriors screaming and
swinging at nothing once the bleeds go
down you go up and do it all over again
then you prep then you vanish again then
you wait and I'm like it's the easiest
thing in the world people complain about
the problem is because it's Capture the
Flag if it was just one-on-one you could
handle the road what do you mean well I
could handle Rogue one-on-one but it's I
had I had a goal I had to go do
something you forget about the guy
behind me yeah so stay on the road it's
the invisibility you could not you
didn't know where to attack they needed
to be like shimmery so you could at
least see them no no that ruins the park
they changed heroes in a storm
absolutely I can't believe we're like
bonding over a while here but here's the
thing
vanilla right before the release of
burning Crusade right was the best It
Ever Was that's it and then once burning
Crusade came out it sucked and then then
what was what was next like Wrath of the
Lich King or something yeah yes that I
was done I just stopped I like flying I
just just it's the last one I played was
around I think I think flying kind of
ruined it there because there it used to
be when you couldn't fly there was so
much to do right and me and my friends
would go glitch hopping and find all the
exploits and then risk getting banned
and we get warnings but we would go
underneath Stormwind and then yeah
because there was a an area where you
could glitch yes I used to go on top of
undercity and they took all of that fun
stuff away it was like they created this
universe that you could go into and play
games and had missions but there was
also I would look we'd look on the map
and be like hey has anyone ever realized
this portion of the continent isn't
we've never been to right we go there
and there's no way in so we start glitch
hopping basically jumping until we find
a way to break through and then we're in
this big flat space with literally
nothing in it and we're on the map then
we message our friends being like look
where we are look where and then they
they took it all away from us did you
get into the center of duskwood you know
there's that big where you see stitches
for the first time you guys know what
I'm talking about yes there's a big like
mountainous area in the middle yeah is
there something in there I never found
anything in there all around Playboys
for playing World War but if can fly you
could probably I didn't fly so you could
probably go up there now I it just
ruined it and that's why I think when
people started releasing the vanilla
versions The Classic that people got
really into it and then blizzard got mad
and sent lawyers to shut them all down
right then launched their version you
know and and I I tried playing vanilla
and I'm like they lost it man it's not
there like all of the fun Shenanigans
were just we're just gonna Harvest so
many peace blooms until I want to blow
my freaking breeds I'm like what am I
doing with my life I could be making a
TV show they need to stop doing
expansions and literally just do wow two
and start a new game from scratch which
is something new and fresh because now
the economies ruined the whole game
makes no sense and I just stopped
playing it I played uh Legion and then
uh I I've I've played like every
expansion then given up really quickly I
cannot find an MMO that's good I think
it's got to be the next evolution of
video gaming which is vrar where you are
in it the reality I really enjoy MMOs
but the cheating just drives me away
every time like there's just so much
cheating that goes on like play DayZ for
example a lot and just like cheater
after cheater after cheating aimbots
yeah I just give up and they can see you
through walls and
you know people doing like head shots
from 200 meters with pistols
yeah we'll grab uh we'll grab a couple
more here okay MF Damien says Rogan used
to have a thick Boston accent and
trained it out maybe that's why yeah
he's got a unique he's got a unique
voice it's like it's you know I don't
know some people could probably do it
it's just some people are easier to
impersonate than other a lot of it's the
body uh structure of the body so like
unless you have Rogan's body you're not
gonna have that horny sound when it
comes out of the mouth you know we got
one more one real quick tadby says have
you heard the insane idea that they are
floating of using brain dead women as
surrogates yes no yeah I've not heard
that news story they said women who are
brain dead could donate their bodies as
for surrogacy that's also the idea
there's also this uh really in
Innovative idea where they're talking
about taking the wombs from transitioned
young girls and implanting them in men
who want to have the full experience it
obviously won't work but that didn't
stop the NIH in the UK from putting a
bunch of money behind this plan they
keep saying it but men don't have the
the pelvis no obviously not but the nah
was doing research and throwing money at
it anyway it's like sex is a spectrum
stuff it's all yes all right everybody
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the share with your
friends become a member at timcast.com
to support our work directly you can
follow the show at timcastirl you can
follow me personally at timcast Jeff do
you want to shout anything out yeah um
you can look for me on Twitter at uh
Jeff younger TX you can also find me at
my sub stack Jeff younger.substat.com
for long form stuff
right on
Libby Emmons I'm at Libby Emmons on
Twitter and you can check out what we're
doing at thepost millennial.com I love
the post-millennial yeah shout out to
the post millennial hey thanks guys Jeff
thanks for coming man that was awesome I
pray for your wife your ex-wife and your
kids the best for everybody involved
this is great thank you really wonderful
to see you dude thank you yeah bye
everyone
and I'm search.com sorry for the air
today guys so just uh had to grab the
mic I was trying to talk too much and uh
I pushed the wrong button it happens
anyways all right everybody thanks for
supporting us thanks for watching we're
gonna have Clips up all throughout the
weekend so you can watch those and other
than that we will see you all back again
Monday but we're gonna have I think
we're having some really big shows next
week stay tuned I think our Wednesday
show I can't say too much but we'll be
in a special location that's what we're
planning no guarantees it's gonna be a
technical hurdle shouldn't be too
complicated but it will be crazy yeah so
uh let me just put it this way I never
like to announce guests because they
might cancel but we have like five
potential very very high profile people
who might come in and out so just we'll
we'll hopefully pull it off thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time cheers